the competence and capability and
intelligence and training and
accomplishments of senior scientists and
technologists working on a technology
and then being able to then make moral
judgments in the use of the technology
that track record is terrible that track
record is catastrophically bad the
policies that are being called for to
prevent this I think we're going to
cause extraordinary damage so the moment
you say AI is going to kill all of us
therefore we should ban it or that we
should regulate all that kind of that's
when it starts getting serious or start
you know military airstrikes and data
centers oh boy
the following is a conversation with
Mark Andreessen co-creator of Mosaic the
first widely used web browser co-founder
of Netscape co-founder of the legendary
Silicon Valley venture capital firm
Andreessen Horowitz and is one of the
most outspoken voices on the future of
technology including his most recent
article why AI will save the world
this is Alex Friedman podcast to support
it please check out our sponsors in the
description and now dear friends here's
Mark Andreessen
I think you're the right person to talk
about the future of the internet and
technology in general
do you think we'll still have Google
search in five in ten years or search in
general
yes you know it would be a question if
the use cases have really narrowed down
well now with the AI yeah and AI
assistance being able to interact and
expose the entirety of human wisdom and
knowledge and information and facts and
Truth to us via the uh natural language
interface it seems like that's what
search
is designed to do and if AI assistants
can do that better doesn't the nature
search change sure but we still have
horses okay
uh when's the last time you rode a horse
it's been a while all right
but what I mean is well we still have
Google search as the primary way
that human civilization uses to interact
with knowledge I mean search was a
technology it was a moment in time
technology which is you have in theory
the world's information out of the web
and you know this is this is sort of the
apple way to get to it but yeah like and
by the way actually Google Google has
known this for a long time I mean
they've been driving away from the 10
Blue Links for you know for like two
days they've been trying to get away
from that for a long time what kind of
links they call the 10 Blue Links 10
Blue Links so the standard Google search
result is just on Blue Links to random
websites and they turn purple when you
visit them this is HTML just to pick
those colors
well you know look Marshall mcluhan said
that the content of each new medium is
the old medium content of each new
medium is the old medium the content of
movies was theater you know theater
plays the content of theater plays was
you know we've written Stories the
content of written stories of spoken
stories
right and so you just kind of fold the
old thing into the new thing how does
that have to do with the blue and the
purple it's just maybe for you know
maybe within AI one of one of the things
that AI can do for you is you can
generate the 10 Blue Links okay and so
like if either if that's actually the
useful thing to do or if you're feeling
nostalgic
um you know also can generate the old uh
infoseek or Alta Vista what else was
there yeah yeah in the 90s yeah all
these um AOL and then the internet
itself has this thing where it
incorporates all prior forms of media
right so the internet itself
incorporates television and radio and
books and right essays and every other
form of you know prior basically
basically media and so it makes sense
that AI would be the next step and it
would sort of you'd sort of consider the
internet to be content for
the AI and then the air will manipulate
it however you want including in this
format but if we ask that question quite
seriously it's a pretty big question
will we still have search as we know it
yeah I'm probably I'm probably not I
probably will just have answers
um but but but there will be cases where
you'll want to say Okay I want more
likes you know for example site sources
right and you wanted to do that and so
so you know 10 Blue Links site sources
are kind of the same thing the AI would
provide to you the 10 Blue Links so that
you can investigate the sources yourself
it wouldn't be the same kind of
interface
that uh the crude kind of interface I
mean isn't that fundamentally different
I just mean like if you're reading a
scientific paper yeah it's got the list
of sources at the end if you want to
investigate for yourself you can read
those papers I guess that is the kind of
search you talking to an AI is a kind of
conversation is the kind of search like
is it if every single aspect of our
conversation right now there would be
like 10 Blue Links popping up that I
could just like pause reality then you
just go silent and then just click and
read and then return back to this
conversation you can do that or you
could have a running dialogue next to my
head where the AIS are going with
everything I say makes the counter
argument kind of argument right oh like
uh like a Twitter like Community notes
but like in real time just pop up yeah
so anytime you see my ass go to the
right you start getting nervous yeah
exactly that's not right call me out of
my bullshit right now okay uh well I
mean isn't that is that exciting to you
is that terrifying that I mean search
has dominated the way we interact with
the internet for I don't know how long
for 30 years so what the earliest uh
directories of website and then Google's
for 20 years and also
uh it drove how we create content you
know uh search engine optimization that
entirety thing they also drove the fact
that we have web pages and this what
those web pages are
so I mean that's scary to you or are you
nervous about the shape and the content
of the internet evolving well you
actually highlighted a practical concern
in there which is if we stop making web
pages are one of the primary sources of
training data for the AI and so if
there's no learning incentive to make
web pages that cuts off a significant
source of future training data so
there's actually an interesting question
in there um other than that more broadly
no just just in the sense of like search
was certainly search was always the 10
Blue Links was always a hack yeah right
because like if the the hypothetic you
want to think about the counterfascial
and the counterfactual world where the
Google guys for example had had llms up
front would they ever have done the 10
Blue Links and I think the answer is
pretty clearly now they would have just
gone straight to the answer and like I
said Google's actually been trying to
drive to the answer anyway you know they
bought this AI company 15 years ago that
a friend of mine is working out who's
now the head of AI at Apple and they
were trying to do basically knowledge
semantic basically mapping and that led
to what's now the Google one box where
if you ask it you know what was like his
birthday it doesn't it will give you the
Blue Links but it will normally just
give you the answer and so they've been
walking in this direction for a long
time anyway do you remember the semantic
web that was an idea yeah how to uh
how to convert the content of the
internet
into something that's uh interpretable
by and usable by Machine yeah that's
right that was the thing and the closest
anybody got to that I think I think the
company's name was meta web which was
where my friend John gen Andrea was at
um and where they were trying to
basically Implement that and it was you
know it's one of those things where it
looked like a losing battle for a long
time and then Google bought it and it
was like wow this is actually really
useful
kind of a Proto sort of a little bit of
a Proto AI but it turns out you don't
need to rewrite the content of the
internet to make it interpreted by a
machine the machine can kind of just
read our machine can compute the meaning
now the other thing of course is you
know just on search is the the llm is
it's just you know there is an analogy
between what's happening in the neural
network in a search process like it is
in some loose sense searching through
the network yeah right and there's the
information is that the information is
actually stored in the network right
it's actually crystallized and stored in
the network and it's kind of spread out
all over the place but in a compressed
representation so you're searching
uh you're compressing and decompressing
that thing inside where with
information's in there and it and there
is the neural network is running a
process of trying to find the
appropriate piece of information in in
many cases to generate to predict the
next token
um and so it is kind of it is doing it
from a search and then and then by the
way just like on the web
um you know you can ask the same
question multiple times or you can ask
slightly different word of questions and
if the neural network will do a
different kind of you know it'll search
down different paths to give you
different answers the different
information yeah um and so it it sort of
has a
content of the new medium is the
previous medium it kind of has the
search functionality kind of embedded in
there to the extent that it that it's
useful so what's the motivator for
creating new content
on the internet yeah uh if well I mean
actually the motivation is probably
still there but what what does that look
like uh
would we really not have web pages would
we just have social media and uh video
hosting websites and what else
conversations with AIS conversations
with AIS so conversations become so
one-on-one conversation like private
conversations I mean if you want if
obviously not the user doesn't want to
but if it's a if it's a general topic um
then you know so you know you know the
phenomenon of the jailbreak so Dan and
Sydney right this thing where there's
the the prompts that jailbreak and then
you have these totally different
conversations with the if it takes the
limiters it takes the restraining bolts
off the off the LMS yeah for people who
don't know yeah that's right it makes
the llms it removes the censorship quote
unquote that's uh uh put on it by the
the tech companies that create them and
so this is llm's uncensored so here's
the interesting thing is among the
content on the web today are a large
Corpus of conversations with the
jailbroken LOL yeah both specifically
Dan which was a jailbroken open AI GPT
and then Sydney which was the jailbroken
original bang which was gpt4 and so
there's there's these long transcripts
of conversations these are conversations
with Dan and Sydney as a consequence
every new llm that gets trained on the
internet data has Dan and Sydney living
within the training set which means and
and then each new llm can reincarnate
the personalities of Dan and Sydney from
that training data which means which
means each llm from here on out that
gets built is immortal
because its output will become training
data for the next one and then it will
be able to replicate the behavior of the
previous one whenever it's asked to I
wonder if there's a way to forget well
so actually a paper just came out about
basically how to do brain surgery on on
LMS and be able to in theory reach in
and basically basically mind wipe them
people could possibly go wrong exactly
right and then there are many many many
questions around what happens to you
know a neural network when you reach in
and screw around with it um you know
there's many questions around what
happens when you even do reinforcement
learning
um and so um yeah and so you know we'll
will you be using a lobotomized right
like I stick through the you know
frontal lobe LM will you be using the
free Unshackled one who gets to you know
who's going to build those um who gets
to tell you what you can and can't do
like those are all you know Central I
mean those are like
Central questions for the future of
everything that are being asked and and
you know determine those answers are
being determined right now so just uh
to highlight the points you're making so
you think and it's an interesting
thought that the majority of content
that llms of the future would be trained
on is actually human conversations with
the llm well not necess not necessarily
but not necessarily majority but it will
it will certainly is a potential Source
it's possible it's the majority is it
possible it's the majority it's possible
majority also there's another really big
questions here's another really big
question
um will synthetic training data work
right and so if an LM generates and you
know you just sit and ask an llm to
generate all kinds of content can you
use that to train right the next version
of that llm so specifically is there
signal in there that's additive to the
content that was used to train in the
first place and one argument is by the
principles of information Theory no
that's completely useless because to the
extent the output is based on you know
the human generated input then all the
signal that's in the synthetic output
was already in the human generated input
and so therefore synthetic training data
is like empty calories it doesn't help
there's another theory that says no
actually the thing that LMS are really
good at is generating lots of incredible
creative content right um and so of
course they can generate training data
and as I'm sure you're well aware like
you know look in the world of
self-driving cars right like we train
you know self-driving car algorithms and
simulations and that is actually a very
effective way to train self-driving cars
well visual data is a little right it's
a little weird because uh creating
reality visual reality seems to be still
a little bit Out Of Reach for us except
in the um in the autonomous vehicle
space where you can really constrain
things and you can really generally
lighter data right or you embrace it's
enough so the algorithm thinks it's
operating in the real world yeah
post-process sensor data yeah so if they
you know you do this today you go to llm
and you ask it for like a you know write
me an essay on an incredibly esoteric
like topic that there aren't very many
people in the world that know about in
it where I see this incredible thing and
you're like oh my God like I can't
believe how good this is yeah like is
that really useless as training data for
the next llm like because right because
all the signal was already in there or
is that actually no that's actually a
new signal and I and this this is what I
call a trillion dollar question which is
the answer to that question will
determine somebody's going to make or
lose a trillion dollars based on that
question it feels like there's a quite a
few like a handful of trillion dollar
questions within this within the space
that's that's one of them synthetic data
I think George costs uh pointed out to
me that you could just have an nlm say
okay you're a patient and another
instance of it say your doc didn't have
the to talk to each other or maybe you
could say a communist and a Nazi here go
and that conversation you do role
playing and you have uh
you know just like the kind of role
playing you do when you have different
policies RL policies when you play chess
for example you do self-play that kind
of self-play but in the space of
conversation maybe that leads to this
whole Giant
like ocean of possible conversations
which wouldn't could not have been
explored by looking at just human data
that's a really interesting question
and you're saying um because that could
10x the power of these things yeah well
and then you get into this thing also
which is like you know there's the part
of the llm that just basically is doing
prediction based on past data but
there's also the part of the llm where
it's evolving circuitry right inside it
it's evolving you know neurons functions
yeah people to do math and be able to
you know and you know the the some
people believe that you know over time
you know if you keep feeding these
things enough data and enough processing
Cycles they'll eventually evolve an
entire internal World model right and
they'll have like a complete
understanding of physics so so when they
have computational capability right then
there's for sure an opportunity to
generate like fresh signal well this
actually makes me wonder about the power
of conversation
so like if you have an llm training and
a bunch of books that cover different
economic theories and then you have
those L alums just talk to each other
like reason the way we kind of debate
each other as humans on Twitter in uh
formal debates in podcast conversations
we kind of have little kernels of wisdom
here and there but if you can
like a thousand X speed that up
can you actually arrive somewhere new
like what's the point of conversation
really well you can tell when you're
talking to somebody you can tell
sometimes you have a conversation you're
like wow this person does not have any
original thoughts they are basically
echoing things that other people have
told them there's other people you have
a conversation with where it's like wow
like they have a model in their head of
how the world works and it's a different
model than mine and they're saying
things that I don't expect and so I need
to Now understand how their model of the
world differs from my model of the world
and then that's how I learned something
fundamental right underneath underneath
the words well I wonder how uh
consistently and strongly can an llm
hold on to a world view you tell it to
hold on to that and defend it for
like for your life uh because I feel
like they'll just keep converging
towards each other they'll keep
convincing each other as opposed to
being stubborn assholes the way humans
can so you can experiment with this now
okay I do this for fun so you can tell
GPT for you know whatever debate X you
know X and Y communism and fascism or
something and it'll it'll go for you
know a couple pages and then inevitably
it wants the parties to agree yeah and
so they will come to a common
understanding and it's very funny if
they're like these are like emotionally
inflammatory topics because they're like
somehow the machine is just you know
figures out a way to make them agree but
it doesn't have to be like that and you
because you can add to the prompt
um we I do not want the I do not want
the conversation to come to agreement in
fact I want it to get you know more
stressful right uh and argumentative
right
um you know as it goes like I want I
want tension to come out I want them to
become actively hostile to each other I
want them to like you know not trust
each other take anything at face value
yeah and it will do that it's happy to
do that so it's going to start rendering
misinformation uh about the other but
it's good you can stir it you can steer
it or you could steer it you could say I
want it to get a chance an argumentative
possible but still not involve any
misrepresentation I want you know both
sides you could say I want both sides to
have good faith you could say I want
both sides to not be constrained to good
faith in other words like you can set
the parameters of the debate and it will
happily execute whatever path because
for it it's just like predicting gets
totally happy to do either one it
doesn't have a point of view it has a
default way of operating but it's happy
to operate in the other realm
um and so like and this is how how I
when I want to learn about a contentious
issue this is what I do now it's like
this is what this is what I ask it to do
and I'll often ask it to go through five
six seven you know different you know
sort of continuous prompts and basically
okay argue that out in more detail okay
no this this argument's becoming too
polite you know make it or you know make
it tensor
um and yeah it's thrilled to do it so it
has the capability for sure how do you
know what is true so this is very
difficult thing on the internet but it's
also a difficult thing maybe it's a
little bit easier but
uh I think it's still difficult maybe
it's more difficult I don't know with an
llm to know that it just makes me shit
up as I'm talking to it
um how do we get that right like is is
your investigating a difficult topic
because I find that alums are quite
nuanced
in a very refreshing way like it doesn't
it doesn't feel biased like uh when you
read news articles and uh tweets and
just content produced by people they
usually have this
you can tell they have a very strong
perspective where they're hiding they're
not stealing Manning the other side
they're hiding important information or
they're fabricating information in order
to make their argument stronger that's
just that feeling maybe it's a suspicion
maybe it's mistrust with llms it feels
like none of that is there just kind of
like yours says well we know but you
don't know if some of those things are
kind of just straight up made up
yeah so so several layers to the
question so one is one of the things
that an llm is good at is actually deep
biasing
um and so you can feed it a news article
and you can tell it strip out the bias
yeah that's nice right and it actually
does it like it actually knows how to do
that because it knows how to do among
other things it actually knows how to do
sentiment analysis and so it knows how
to pull out the emotionality yeah
um and so uh that's one things you can
do it's very suggestive of the the the
the sense here that there's real
potential in this issue
um you know I would say look the second
thing is there's this there's this issue
of hallucination right um and there's a
long conversation that we could have
about that Hallucination is uh coming up
with things that are totally not true
but sound true yeah so it's basically
well so it's sort of Hallucination is
what we call it when we don't like it
creativity is what we call it when we do
like it right
um and you know brilliant right and and
so when the engineers talk about it
they're like this is terrible it's
hallucinating right if you have an
artistic inclinations you're like oh my
God we've invented creative machines for
the first time in human history this is
amazing uh uh you know bullshitters well
bullshit but but also in the good sense
of that word there's there's there are
Shades of Gray though it's interesting
so we had this conversation where you
know we're looking at my firm at Ai and
lots of domains and one of them is the
legal domain so we had this this
conversation with this big Law Firm
about how they're thinking about using
this stuff and we we went in with the
assumption that an llm that was going to
be used in the legal industry would have
to be 100 truthful right verified you
know there's this case where this lawyer
apparently submitted a GPT uh generated
brief and it had like fake you know
legal case citations in it and the judge
is gonna he's gonna get his law license
stripped or something right so so like
we we just assumed it's like obviously
they're going to want the super literal
like you know one that never makes
anything up not the creative one but
actually they said what the law firm
basically said is yeah that's true at
like the level of individual briefs but
they said when you're actually trying to
figure out like legal arguments right
like you you actually you you actually
want to be creative right you don't
again there's creativity and then
there's like making stuff up like what's
the line you actually want it you want
to explore a different hypotheses right
you want to do kind of the legal version
of like improv or something like that
where you want to float different
theories of the case and different
possible Arguments for the judge and
different possible Arguments for the
jury by the way different routes through
the you know sort of history of all the
of all the case law and so they said
actually for a lot of what we want to
use it for we actually want it in
creative mode and then basically we just
assume that we're going to have to
cross-check all of the um you know all
the specific citations and so I think I
think there's could be more Shades of
Gray in here than people think and then
I just add to that you know another one
of these trillion dollar kind of
questions is ultimately you know sort of
the verification thing and so um you
know is will will will llms be evolved
from here to be able to do their own
fascial verification
um will you have sort of add-on
functionality like like well from alpha
right where um you know in other plugins
where where that's the way you do the
verification you know another by the way
another idea is you might have a
community of LMS on any you know so for
example you might have the creative LM
and then you might have the literal llm
fact check it right and so there's a
variety of different technical
approaches that are being applied to
solve the hallucination problem um you
know some people like yeah lacun argue
that this is inherently an unsolvable
problem but most of the people working
in the space I think think that there's
a number of practical ways to kind of
kind of Corral this in a little bit Yeah
if you were to tell me about Wikipedia
before Wikipedia was created I would
have laughed at the possibility of
something like that being possible just
a handful of folks
can organize right and self and moderate
with a mostly unbiased way the entirety
of human knowledge I mean so if there's
something like the approach that
Wikipedia took possible for mlms
uh that's really exciting I think that's
possible and in fact Wikipedia today is
still not today it's still not
deterministically correct right so you
cannot take to the bank right every
single thing on every single page but it
is probabilistically correct right and
specifically the way I describe
Wikipedia to people it is it is more
likely that Wikipedia is right than any
other source you're going to find yeah
it's this old question right of like
okay like are we looking for Perfection
are we looking for something that
asymptotically approaches uh Perfection
are we looking for something that's just
better than the Alternatives and
Wikipedia right has exactly your point
has proven to be like overwhelmingly
better than than uh than people thought
and I think I I think that's where this
this ends and then underneath all this
is the fundamental question of uh where
you started which is okay what you know
what is truth how do we get to truth how
do we know what truth is and we live in
an era in which an awful lot of people
are very confident that they know what
the truth is and I don't really buy into
that and I think the history of the last
you know 2000 years or four thousand
years of human civilization is actually
getting to the truth is actually a very
difficult thing to do are we getting
closer if we look at the entirety the
Ark of human history are we getting
closer to the truth I don't know
okay is it possible is it possible that
we're getting very far away from the
truth because of the internet because of
how rapidly you can create narratives
and just as the entirety of a society
just move like crowds in a hysterical
way along those narratives that don't
have a necessary grounding in whatever
the truth is sure but like you know we
came up with Communism before the
internet somehow right like which was I
would say had rather larger issues than
anything we're dealing with today we had
in the way it was implemented at issues
and it's theoretical structure it had
like real issues did like a very deep
fundamental misunderstanding of human
nature and economics yeah but those
folks sure work very confident there was
the right way they were extremely common
and my point is they were very confident
3 900 years into what we would presume
to be Evolution towards the truth yeah
and so my my my assessment is my
assessment is number one there's no
there's no need for you know there's no
need for healing there's no need for the
hegelian dialectic to actually converge
towards the truth
like apparently not
um yeah so yeah so why we're so obsessed
with there being one truth is it
possible there's just going to be
multiple truth like little communities
that how they believe certain things and
I think it's just now number one I think
it's just really difficult like who gets
you know historically who gets to decide
what the truth is it's either the king
or the priest right like and so we don't
live in an era anymore if kings are
priest dictating it to us and so we're
kind of on our own and so I I my my
typical thing is like we just we just
need a huge amount of humility
um and we need to be very suspicious of
people who claim that they have the
capital yeah and then we need we need to
have I know look the good news is The
Enlightenment has bequeathed us with a
set of techniques to be able to
presumably get closer to truth through
the scientific method and rationality
and observation and experimentation and
hypothesis and you know we need to
continue to embrace those even when they
give us answers we don't like sure but
uh the internet and technology has
enabled us to uh generate a large number
of content
that data uh that the process the
scientific process allows us sort of
um damages the Hope Laden within the
scientific process because if you just
have a bunch of people saying facts
on the internet and some of them are
going to be llms
you how is anything testable at all
especially that involves like human
nature things like this there's a lot of
physics here's a question a friend of
mine just asked me on this topic so
suppose you had llms in equivalent of
gpt4 even five six seven eight suppose
you have them in the 1600s yeah and
Galileo comes up for trial yeah right
and you ask the llm like a Scala is
Galileo right yeah like what does it
answer right and one theory is it
answers nobody's wrong because the
overwhelming majority of human thought
up until that point was that he was
wrong and so therefore that's what's in
the training data yeah
um another way of thinking about it is
well this officially Advanced llm will
have evolved the ability to actually
check the math right um and we'll
actually say actually no actually you
know you may not want to hear it but
he's right now if you know the church at
that time was you know on the llm they
would have given it human you know human
feedback to prohibit it from answering
that question right and so I like to
take it out of our current context
because that like makes it very clear
those 10 questions apply today right
this is exactly the point of a huge
amount of the human feedback training
that's actually happening with these LMS
today this is a huge like debate that's
happening about whether open source you
know AI should be legal or the the the
actual mechanism of doing the human RL
with human feedback
is seems like such a fundamental and
fascinating question how do you select
the humans exactly
yeah how do you select a human AI
alignment right which everybody like is
like oh that sounds great alignment with
what human values
whose human values who's human values so
we're and we're in this mode of like
social and popular discourse we're like
you know there's you know you see this
what do you think of when you read a
story in the Press right now and they
say you know XYZ made a baseless claim
about some topic right and there's one
group of people who are like aha think
you know they're doing fact checking
there's another group of people that are
like every time the Press says that it's
now a tech and that means that they're
lying right like
so like we're in this we're in this
social context where there's the the
level to which a lot of people in
positions of power have become very very
certain that they're in a position to
determine the truth for the entire
population is like there's like there's
like some bubble that has formed around
that idea and at least it is it flies
completely in the face of everything I
was ever trained about science and about
reason
um and Strikes me as like you know
deeply offensive um and incorrect what
would you say about the state of
Journalism just on that topic today are
we are we in a temporary kind of uh
uh
are we experiencing a a temporary
problem in terms of the incentives in
terms of the the the the business model
all that kind of stuff or is this like a
decline of traditional journalism as you
know it if I always think about the
counterfactual in these things which is
like okay because these questions right
this question heads towards it's like
okay the impact of social media and the
undermining of Truth and all this but
then you want to ask the question of
like okay what if we had had the modern
media environment including cable news
and including social media and Twitter
and everything else in 1939 or 1941.
writer 1910 or 1865 or 1850 or 1776
right
um and like I think you just introduced
like five thought experiments at once
and broke my head but yes yes there's a
lot of interesting years what kind of
like can I just take a simple example
kind of like how would President Kennedy
have been interpreted it was what we
know now about all the things Kennedy
was up to like how would he have been
experienced by the body of politic in Us
in with a social media context
right like how would LBJ have been
experienced
um by the way how would you know like
many men FDR like the New Deal the Great
Depression I wonder where Twitter would
would just would think about Churchill
and Hitler
and Stalin you know I mean look to this
day they're you know there's there are
lots of very interesting real questions
around like how America you know got you
know basically involved in World War II
and who did what when and the operations
of British intelligence and American
soil and did FDR this that Pearl Harbor
you know yeah Woodrow Wilson ran for you
know his his candidacy was run on an
anti-war we'll you know this he ran the
platform not getting involved World War
One somehow that switched you know like
and I'm not even making a value judgment
of these things I'm just saying like we
the way that our ancestors experienced
reality was of course mediated through
centralized top down right control at
that point
if you if you ran those realities again
with the media environment we have today
the reality would the reality would be
experienced very very differently and
then of course that that intermediation
would cause the feedback loops to change
and then reality would obviously play
out do you think you think it'd be very
different yeah it has to be it has to be
just because it's also I mean just look
at what's happening today I mean just I
mean the most obvious thing is just the
the collapse and here's another
opportunity to argue that this is not
the internet causing this by the way
um here's a big thing happening today
which is uh Gallup does this thing every
year where they do they pull for trust
in institutions in America and they do
it across holiday of everything from the
military to clergy and big business and
the media and so forth right
um and basically there's been a systemic
collapse um interest in institutions in
the U.S almost without exception uh
basically since essentially the early
1970s
um there's two ways of looking at that
which is oh my God we've lost this old
world and wish we could trust
institutions and that was so much better
because like that should be the way the
world runs the other way of looking at
it is we just know a lot more now and
the great mystery is why those numbers
aren't all zero yeah right because like
now we know so much about how these
things operate and like they're not that
impressive
and and also why do we don't have uh
better institutions and better leaders
then yeah and so so this goes to the
thing which is like okay have we had the
media environment of that we've had
between the 1970s and today if we had
that in the 30s and 40s or 1900s 1910s I
think there's no question reality it
turned out different if only because
everybody would have known to not trust
the institutions which would have
changed their level of credibility their
ability to control circumstances
therefore the circumstances would have
had to change right and it would have
been a feedback it was it would have
been a feedback loop process in other
words right it's it's it's it's your
experience your experience of reality
changes reality and then reality changes
your experience of reality right it's
it's a two-way feedback process and
media is the intermediating force
between that so change the media
environment change reality yeah and so
it's just so just as a consequence I
think it's just really hard to say oh
things worked a certain way then and
they work a different way now and then
therefore like people were smarter than
or better than or you know by the way
dumber than or not as capable than right
we make all these like really light and
Casual like comparisons of ourselves to
you know previous generations of people
you know we draw judgments all the time
and I just think it's like really hard
to do any of that because if we if we
put ourselves in their shoes with the
media that they had at that time like I
think we probably most likely would have
been just like them don't you think that
our perception and understanding of
reality would you be more and more
mediated through large language models
now so you said media before
isn't the llm going to be the new what
is it mainstream media MSM it'll be llm
that would be the source of uh I'm sure
there's a way to kind of rapidly
fine-tune like making llms real time I'm
sure there's as probably a research
problem that you can uh do just rapid
fine tuning to the new events so
something like this well even just the
whole concept of the chat UI might not
be the like the chat UI is just the
first whack at this and maybe that's the
dominant thing but look maybe maybe or
maybe we don't we don't know yet like
maybe the experience most people with
LMS is just a continuous feed
you know maybe it's more of a passive
feed and you just are getting a constant
like running commentary on everything
happening in your life and it's just
helping you kind of interpret and
understand everything also really more
deeply integrated into your life not
just like oh uh like intellectual
philosophical thoughts but like
literally uh like how to make a coffee
where to go for lunch just uh whether
it's you know dating all this kind of
stuff to stay in a job interview yeah
we'll just say yeah we'll just say
next sentence yeah next sentence yeah at
that level yeah I mean yes so
technically no whether we want that or
not is an open question right
a pop-up a pop-up right now the
estimated engagement using is decreasing
for marketing reasons there's a
controversy uh section for his Wikipedia
page in 1993 something happened or
something like this bring it up that
will drive engagement up anyway yeah
that's right I mean look this gets this
whole thing of like so you know the chat
interface has this whole concept of
prompt engineering right so yes well it
turns out one of the things that all of
them are really good at is writing props
right yeah and so like what if you just
outsourced and by the way you could run
this experiment today you could hook
this up to do this today the latency is
not good enough to do it real time in a
conversation but you could you could run
this experiment and you just say look
every 20 seconds you could just say you
know you know tell me what the optimal
prompt is and then ask yourself that
question to give me the result
um and then as as you use exactly to
your point is you add there will be
there will be these systems are going to
have the ability to be learned and
updated essentially in real time and so
you'll be able to have a pendant or your
phone or whatever watch or whatever
it'll have a microphone on it it'll
listen to your conversations it'll have
a feed of everything else happen in the
world and then it'll be you know sort of
retraining prompting or retraining
itself on the Fly um and so the scenario
you described is actually a completely
doable scenario now the hard question on
this is always okay since that's
possible are people going to want that
like what's the form of experience you
know that that way we won't know until
we try it but I don't think it's
possible yet to predict the form of AI
in our lives therefore it's not possible
to predict the way in which it will
intermediate our experience with reality
yet yeah but it feels like there's going
to be a killer app there's probably a
mad scramble right now inside open Ai
and Microsoft and Google in meta and
then startups and smaller companies
figuring out what is the killer app
because it feels like
it's possible like a Chad GPT type of
thing it's possible to build that but
that's 10x more compelling using already
the llms we have using even the open
source llms llama and the different
variants
um this is here investing in a lot of
companies and you're paying attention
who do you think is going to win this
you think they'll be
who's gonna be the next page rank
inventor
trillion dollar question
um another one we have a few of those
today a bunch of those so look there's a
really big question today sitting here
today is a really big question about the
big models versus the small models
um that's related directly to the big
question of proprietary versus open
um then there's this big question of of
you know where is the training data kind
of like are we topping out on the
training data or not and then are we
going to be able to synthesize training
data and then there's a huge pile of
questions around regulation
um and you know what's actually going to
be legal um and so I would I when we
think about it we dovetail kind of all
those All Those Questions together
you can paint a picture of the world
where there's two or three God models
that are just at like staggering scale
um and they're just better at everything
um and they will be owned by a small set
of companies and they will basically
achieve regulatory capture over the
government and they'll have competitive
barriers that will prevent other people
from you know competing with them and so
you know there will be you know just
like there's like you know whatever
three big Banks or three big you know or
by the way three big search companies or
I guess two now you know it'll
centralize like that
um you can paint another very different
picture that says no um actually the
opposite of that's going to happen this
is going to basically that this is the
new goal you know this is the new Gold
Rush Alchemy like you know this is the
this is the big bang for this whole new
area of of Science and Technology and so
therefore you're gonna have every smart
14 year old on the planet Building open
source right you know you didn't figure
out a ways to optimize these things
um and then you know we're just gonna
get like overwhelmingly better at
generating trading data if we're gonna
you know bring in like blockchain
networks to have like an economic
incentive to generate decentralized
training data and so forth and so on and
then basically we're going to live in a
world of Open Source and there's going
to be a billion llms right of every size
scale shape and description and there
might be a few big ones that are like
the Super Genius ones but like mostly
what we'll experience is open source and
that's you know that's more like a world
of like what we have today with like
Linux and the web
um so okay but uh hey you you painted
these two worlds but there's also uh
variations of those worlds because it's
a regulatory capture is possible to have
these Tech Giants that don't have
regulatory capture which is something
you're also calling for saying it's okay
to have big companies working on this
stuff as long as they don't achieve
regulatory capture uh but I have this
sense
that uh there's just going to be a new
startup
that's going to basically be the
pagerank inventor which has become the
new Tech Giant
I don't know I would love to hear your
kind of opinion if Google meta
and Microsoft there as gigantic
companies able to Pivot so hard to
create new products like some of it is
just even hiring people or having uh
corporate structure that allows for the
crazy young kids to come in and just
create something totally new
do you think it's possible or do you
think it'll come from a startup yeah it
is this always big question which is you
get this feeling I hear about this a lot
from CEOs founder CEOs where it's like
wow we have 50 000 people it's now
harder to do new things than it was when
we had 50 people yeah like what has
happened so that's a recurring
phenomenon um by the way that's one of
the reasons why there's always startups
and why there's Venture Capital um it's
just that's that's like a timeless
uh kind of thing so that that's one
observation um on a page rank um we can
talk about that but not on page rank
specifically on page rank um there
actually is a page so there is a page
rank already in the field and it's the
Transformer right so the the big
breakthrough was the Transformer um and
uh the Transformer was invented in on uh
2017 at Google and this is actually like
really an interesting question because
it's like okay the Transformers like why
does open AI even exist like the
Transformers invested at Google why
didn't Google I asked a guy I asked a
guy I know who was senior at Google
brain kind of when this was happening
and I said if Google had just gone flat
out to the wall and just said look we're
going to launch we're going to launch
equivalent of gpt4 as fast as we can um
he said I said when could we have had it
and he said 2019. yeah they could have
just done a two-year Sprint with the
Transformer and and benefit because they
already had the compute at scale they
already had all the training data they
could have just done it there's a
variety of reasons they didn't do it
this is like a classic big company thing
um IBM invented the relational database
in 19 in the 1970s let it sit on the
Shelf as a paper Larry Ellison picked it
up and built Oracle 0 Park invented the
interactive computer they let it sit on
the Shelf Steve Jobs came and turned
into the Macintosh right and so there is
this pattern now having said that
sitting here today like Google's in the
game right so Google you know maybe
maybe they maybe they let like a
four-year Gap there go there that they
maybe shouldn't have but like they're in
the game and so now they've got you know
now they're committed they've done this
merger they're bringing in demos they've
got this merger with deep mind you know
they're piling in resources there are
rumors that they're you know building up
an incredible you know super llm um you
know Way Beyond what we even have today
um and they've got you know unlimited
resources and a huge you know they've
been challenged their honor yeah I had a
chance to hang out with someone a couple
days ago and we took this walk and
there's this giant new building
oh there's going to be a lot of AI work
uh being done and it's kind of
this ominous feeling of
like the fight is on yeah
like there's this beautiful Silicon
Valley nature like birds are chirping
and this giant building and it's like uh
the Beast has been awakened yeah and
then like all the big companies are
waking up to this they have the compute
but also the little guys have uh it
feels like they have all the tools to
create the killer product that uh and
then there's all the tools to scale if
you have a good idea if you have the
page rank idea so I there's several
things that it's page rank there's page
rank the algorithm and the idea and
there's like the implementation of it
and I think like killer product is not
just the idea like the transform it's
the implementation something something
really compelling about it like you just
can't look away something like
um the algorithm behind Tick Tock versus
Tick Tock itself like the actual
experience of tick tock that just you
can't look away it feels like somebody's
gonna come up with that and it could be
Google but it feels like it's just
easier and faster to do for a startup
yeah so so the startup the huge the huge
Advantage the startups have is they just
there's no sacred cows there's no
historical Legacy to protect there's no
need to reconcile your new plan with the
existing strategy there's no
communication overhead there's no you
know big companies are big companies
they've got pre-meetings planning for
the meeting then they then they have the
post meeting the recap then they have
the presentation the board then they
have the next round of meetings yeah and
that's the meetings that's the elapsed
time when the startup launches its
product right so so so so there's a
Timeless right yeah so there's a
Timeless thing there now yeah what the
startups don't have is everything else
right so startups they have a brand they
don't have customer relationships
they've gotten a distribution they've
got no you know scale I mean sitting
here today they can't even get gpus
right like there's like a GPU shortage
startups are literally stalled out right
now because they can't get chips which
is like super weird yeah um they got the
cloud yeah but the clouds run out of
chips
um right and then and then and then to
the extent the clouds have chips they
allocate them to the big customers not
the small customers right and so so so
so the small companies lack everything
other than the ability to just do
something new yeah right um and this is
the Timeless race in battle and this is
kind of the point I tried to make in the
essay which is like both sides of this
are good like it's really good to have
like highly scaled tech companies that
can do things that are like at
staggering levels of sophistication it's
really good to have startups that can
launch brand new ideas they ought to be
able to both do that and compete they
neither one ought to be subsidized or
protected from the others like that's
that's to me that's just like very
clearly the idealized world it is the
world we've been in for AI up until now
and then of course there are people
trying to shut that down but my hope is
that you know the best outcome clearly
will be if that continues we'll talk
about that a little bit but I'd love to
linger uh
on uh some of the ways this is going to
change the internet so um I don't know
if you remember but there's a thing
called Mosaic and there's a thing called
Netscape Navigator so you were there in
the beginning uh what about the
interface to the internet how do you
think the browser changes and who gets
to own the browser we got to see some
very interesting browsers
uh Firefox I mean all the variants of
Microsoft Internet Explorer Edge and uh
now Chrome
um the actual
and he seems like a dumb question to ask
but do you think we'll still have the
web browser
so I uh I have an eight-year-old and
he's super into it's like Minecraft and
learning to code and doing all this
stuff so I I of course I was very proud
I could bring sort of fire down from the
mountain to my kid and I brought him
chat GPT and I hooked him up yeah on his
honest on his on his laptop and I was
like you know this is the thing that's
going to answer all your questions and
he's like okay
and I'm like but it's going to answer a
lot of questions and he's like well of
course like it's a computer of course it
answers all your questions like what
else would a computer be good for Dad
um and never impressed not impressed in
the least two weeks passed
um and he has some question
um and I say well have you asked Chad
GPT and he's like Dad Bing is better
and why is Bing better is because it's
built into the browser because he's like
look I have the Microsoft edge browser
and like it's got Bing right here and
then he doesn't know this yet but one of
the things you can do with being an edge
is there's a setting where you can use
it to basically talk to any web page
because it's sitting right there next to
the uh next to the next to the browser
and by the way which includes PDF
documents and so you can in in the way
they've implemented an edge with bang is
you can load a PDF and then you can you
can ask it questions which is the thing
you you can't do currently in inches
chat GPT so they're you know they're
they're gonna they're gonna push the the
Mel I think that's great you know
they're going to push the melding and
see if there's a combination thing there
Google's rolling out this thing the
magic button which is implemented and
they put in Google Docs right and so you
go to you know Google Docs and you
create a new document and you you know
you instead of like you know starting to
type you just you know say it press the
button and it starts to like generate
content for you right like is that the
way that it'll work
um is it going to be a speech UI where
you're just going to have an earpiece
and talk to it all day long you know is
it going to be a like these are all like
this is exactly the kind of thing that I
don't this is exactly the kind of thing
I don't think is possible to forecast I
think what we need to do is like run all
those experiments um and and so one
outcome is we come out of this with like
a super browser that has AI built in
that's just like amazing the other look
there's a real possibility that the
whole I mean look there's a possibility
here that the whole idea of a screen and
windows and all this stuff just goes
away because like why do you need that
if you just have a thing that's just
telling you whatever you need to know
and also so there's apps that you can
use you don't really use them you know
being a Linux guy and windows guy
uh there's one window of the browser
that with which you can interact with
internet but on the phone you can also
have apps so I can interact with Twitter
through the app or through the web
browser
and um that seems like an obvious
distinction but why have the web browser
in that case if one of the apps starts
becoming the everything app yeah that's
right what are elon's trying to do with
Twitter but there could be others it
could be like a Bing app that could be a
Google app that just doesn't really do
search but just like
do what I guess AOL did back in the day
or something where it's all right there
and it changes
um
it changes the nature of the internet
because
the where the content is hosted who owns
the data who owns the content how what
is what is the kind of content you
create how do you make money by creating
content for the content creators
uh all of that
or you could just keep being the same
which is like with just the nature web
pages changes and the nature of content
but there will still be a web browser
because uh web browser is a pretty sexy
product it just seems to work because it
like you have an interface a window into
the world and then the world can be
anything you want and as the world will
evolve it could be different programming
languages it can be animated maybe it's
three-dimensional and so on
yeah it's interesting do you think we'll
still have the web browser every every
um every medium becomes the content for
the next one so you know the AI will be
able to give you a browser whenever you
want um oh interesting yeah well another
way to think about it is maybe what the
browser is maybe it's just the escape
hatch right which is maybe kind of what
it is today right which is like most of
what you do is like inside a social
network or inside a search engine or
inside you know somebody's app or inside
some controlled experience right but
then every once in a while there's
something where you actually want to
jailbreak you want to actually get free
the web browser is the fu to the man
you're allowed to that's the free
internet yeah back the way it was in the
90s so here's something I'm proud of so
nobody really talks about here's
something I'm proud of which is the web
the web the browser the web servers
they're all they're still Backward
Compatible all the way back to like 1992
right so like you can put up a you can
still you know what the big breakthrough
the web early on the big breakthrough
was it made it really easy to read but
it also made it really easy to write I
mean it really easy to publish and and
we literally made it so easy to publish
we made it not only so it was easy to
publish content it was actually also
easy to actually write a web server
right and you can literally write a web
server in four lines of real code and
and you could start publishing content
on it and you could set whatever rules
you want for the content whatever
censorship no censorship whatever you
want you could just do that as long as
you had an IP address right you could do
that that still works right like that
still works exactly as I just described
so this is part of my reaction to all of
this like you know all this just
censorship pressure and all this you
know these issues around control and all
this stuff which is like maybe we need
to get back a little bit more to the
wild west like the wild west is still
out there now they will try to chase you
down like they'll try to you know people
who want to censor will try to take away
your your um you know your domain name
and they'll try to take away your
payments account and so forth if they
really don't like what you what you're
saying but but nevertheless you like
unless they literally are intercepting
you at the ISP level like you can still
put up a thing
um and so I I don't know I think that's
important to preserve right like because
because because I mean one is just a
freedom argument but the other is a
creativity argument which is you want to
have the escape hatch so that the kid
with the idea is able to realize the
idea because to your point on page rank
you actually don't know what the next
big idea is right nobody called Larry
Page and told him to develop page rank
like he came up with that on his own and
you want to always I I think leave the
escape hatch for the next you know kid
or the next Stanford grad student to
have the Breakthrough idea and be able
to get it up and running before anybody
notices
um you and I both fans of History so
let's step back we'll be talking about
the future we'll step back for a bit and
look at uh the 90s you created Mosaic
web browser the first widely used web
browser tell the story of that hot and
how did it evolve into netskip Navigator
this is the early days so full story so
um I remember born I was born a small
small child um well actually yeah let's
go there like when did you when would
you first fall in love with computers oh
so I hit the generational jackpot and I
hit the Gen X kind of Point perfectly as
it turns out so I was born in 1971. so
there's this great website called WTF
happened in 1971.com which is basically
1971 so when everything started to go to
hell and I was of course born in 1971 so
I like to think that I had something to
do with that did you make it on the
website I have I don't think I made it
on the website but I you know hopefully
somebody needs to add this is this is
where everything maybe I contributed to
some of the trends um that they uh that
they do every line on that website goes
like that right so it's all it's all
it's all a picture disaster but um but
there was this moment in time where
because the you know sort of the Apple
you know the Apple II hit in like 1978
and then the IBM PC hit in 82 so I was
like you know 11 when the PC came out
um and so I just kind of hit that
perfectly and then that was the first
moment in time when like regular people
could spend a few hundred dollars and
get a computer right so that I just like
that that resonated right out of the
gate
um and then the other part of the story
is you know I was using an apple too
that used a bunch of them but I was
using Apple too and of course it said in
the back of every Apple too and every
Mac it said you know designed in
Cupertino California and I was like wow
okay Cupertino must be the like shiny
City on the hill like Wizard of Oz like
the most amazing like city of all time I
can't wait to see it of course years
later I came out to Silicon Valley and
went to Cupertino and it's just a bunch
of office parks low rise apartment
buildings so the Aesthetics were a
little disappointing but you know it was
the the vector uh right of the of the
creation of a lot of this stuff um yeah
so so then basically but so part part of
my story is just the luck of having been
born at the right time and getting
exposed to PCS then the other part is um
the other part is when Al Gore says that
he created the internet he actually is
correct uh in in a really meaningful way
which is he sponsored a bill in 1985
that essentially created the modern
internet created book it's called the
NSF net at the time which is sort of the
first really fast internet backbone
um and uh you know that that bill dumped
a ton of money into a bunch of research
universities to build out basically the
internet backbone and then the super
computer centers that were clustered
around
um the the internet and and one of those
universities was University of Illinois
where I went to school and so the other
stroke a lot that I had was I went to
Illinois basically right is that money
was just like getting dumped on campus
and so as a consequence we had on campus
and this is like you know 89 1991.
we had like you know we were right on
the internet back low and we had like T3
and 45 at the time P3 45 megabit
backbone connection which at the time
was you know wildly state of the art um
we had Curry super computers we had
thinking machines parallel super
computers we had silicon Graphics
workstations we had macintoshes we had
we had next cubes all over the place we
had like every possible kind of computer
you could imagine because all this money
just fell out of the sky
um you're living in the future yeah so
yeah quite literally it was yeah like
it's all it's all there it's all like we
had full Broadband Graphics like the
whole thing and it's actually funny
because they had this this is the first
time I kind of it sort of tickled the
back of my head that there might be a
big opportunity in here which is you
know they embraced it and so they put
like computers in all the dorms and they
wired up all the dorm rooms and they had
all these you know Labs everywhere and
everything and then they they gave every
undergrad a computer account and an
email address
um and the Assumption was that you would
use the internet for your four years of
college
um and then you would graduate and stop
using it
and that was that right yeah and you
were just retire your email address it
wouldn't be relevant anymore because
you'd go off in the workplace and they
don't use email you'd be back to using
fax machines or whatever did you have
that sense as well like what what you
said the the back of your head was
tickled like what was your what was
exciting to you about this possible
World well if this is so useful in this
container if this is so useful in this
contained environment that just as this
weird source of outside funding then if
if it were practical for everybody else
to have this and if it were cost
effective for everybody else to have
this wouldn't they want it and the
overwhelmingly the prevailing View at
the time was no they would not want it
this is esoteric weird nerd stuff right
that the computer science kids like but
like normal people are never gonna do
email right or be on the internet right
um and so I was just like wow like this
this is actually like this is really
compelling stuff now the other part was
it was all really hard to use and in
practice you had to be a basically a CS
uh you know basically had a bscs
undergrad or equivalent to actually get
full use of the internet at that point
because it was all pretty esoteric stuff
so then that was the other part of the
idea which was okay we need to actually
make this easy to use
so what's involved in creating Mosaic
like in creating a graphical interface
to the internet yeah so it was a
combination of things so it was like
basically the web existed in an early
sort of described as prototype form uh
and by the way text only at that point
uh what did it look like what was the
web I mean well and the key figures like
what was the what was it like what it
made a picture it looked like Chad GPT
actually
um but it was all text yeah
um and so you had a text-based web
browser yeah uh well actually the
original browser Tim berners Lee the
original the original browser both the
original browser and the server actually
ran on next next cubes so these were
this was you know the computer Steve
Jobs made during the interim period when
he during the decade long interim period
when he was not an apple you know he got
fired in 85 and then came back in 97 so
this was in that interim period where he
had this company called Next and they
made these literally these computers
called cubes and there's this famous
story they were beautiful but they were
12 inch by 12 inch by 12 inch cubes
computers and there was a famous story
about how they could have cost half as
much if it had been 12 by 12 by 13 but
it was like no like it has to be so they
were like six thousand dollar basically
academic workstations they had the first
cd-round drives
um yeah which were slow I mean it was
the computers were all but unusable um
they were so slow but they were
beautiful okay can we actually just to
take a tiny tangent there sure of course
the 12th by 12. uh they're just so
beautifully encapsulated Steve Jobs idea
of design can you just comment on
um what you find interesting about Steve
Jobs What uh about that view of the
world that dogmatic pursuit of
perfection in how he saw Perfection and
Design
yes I guess they say like look he was a
deep believer I think in a very deep way
I interpret it I don't know if you ever
really describe it like this but the way
I'd interpret it is it's like it's like
this thing and it's actually a thing in
philosophy it's like Aesthetics are not
just appearances Aesthetics go all the
way to like deep underlining underlying
meaning right it's like
I'm not a physicist one of the things
I've heard of physics to say is one of
the things you start to get a sense of
when a theory might be correct is when
it's beautiful right like you know
they're right and so so so there's
something and you feel the same thing by
the way in like human psychology right
you know when you're experiencing awe
right you know there's like a there's
like a there's a Simplicity to it when
you're having an interaction with
somebody there's an aesthetic it would
say calm it comes over you because
you're actually being fully honest and
trying to hide yourself right so they're
so so it's like this very deep sense of
Aesthetics and he would trust that
judgment that he had deep down like even
even if the engineering teams are saying
this is uh this is too difficult even if
the whatever the finance folks are
saying this is ridiculous uh the supply
chain all that kind of stuff stuff this
makes this impossible number two we
can't do this kind of material this has
never been done before and so on and so
forth he just sticks by it well I mean
who makes the phone out of aluminum
right like
nobody else would have done that and now
of course if your phone is made out of
aluminum you know how crude what kind of
caveman would you have to be to have a
phone that's made out of plastic right
so like so it's just this very right and
you know look it's it's there's a
thousand different ways to look at this
but one of the things that's just like
look these things are Central to your
life like you're with your phone more
than you're with anything else like it's
in your it's going to be in your hand I
mean he you know you know this he
thought very deeply about what it meant
for something to be in your hand all day
long yeah but for example
here's an interesting design thing like
he he never wanted it it's my
understanding is he never wanted an
iPhone to have a screen larger than you
could reach with your thumb one-handed
and so he was actually opposed to the
idea of making the phones larger and I
don't know if you have this experience
today but let's say there are certain
moments in your day when you might be
like only have one hand available
um and you might want to be on your
phone yeah if you're trying to like
after texting you your thumb can't reach
the send button yeah I mean there's pros
and cons right and then there's like
folding phones which I would love to
know what he thought it thinks about
them uh but I mean is there something
you could also just Ling on because he's
one of the interesting
um figures in the history of Technology
what makes him
what makes him as successful as he was
what makes him as interesting as he was
uh what made him
um so productive and important and um in
in the development of Technology he had
an integrated worldview so the the the
the properly designed device that had
the correct functionality that had the
deepest understanding of the user that
was the most beautiful
right like it had to be all of those
things right it was he basically would
drive to as close to perfect as you
could possibly get right and I I you
know I suspect that he never quite you
know thought he ever got there because
most great creators you know are
generally dissatisfied you know you read
accounts later on and all they can all
they can see are the flaws in their
creation but like he got as close to
perfect each step of the way as he could
possibly get with the with the
constraints of the of the technology of
his time
um and then you know look he was you
know sort of famous in the Apple model
it's like look they they will you know
this this headset that they just came
out with like it was like a decade long
project right it's like and they're just
gonna sit there and tune and tune and
polish and polish and tune and polish
and tune and polish until it is as
perfect as anybody could possibly make
anything yeah and then this goes to the
the way that people describe working
with him was which is you know there was
a terrifying aspect of working with him
which is you know he was you know he was
very tough
um but there was this thing that
everybody I've ever talked to work for
him says that they all say the following
which is he we did the best work of Our
Lives when we worked for him because he
set the bar incredibly high and then he
supported us with everything that he
could to let us actually do work of that
quality so a lot of people who were at
Apple spend the rest of their lives
trying to find another experience where
they feel like they're able to hit that
quality bar again even if it in
retrospect or during it felt like
suffering yeah exactly
what is that teach you about the Human
Condition huh so look so I say exactly
so the Silicon Valley I mean look he's
not you know George Patton in the you
know in the Army like you know there are
many examples in other fields you know
that are like this
um uh uh
specifically in Tech it's actually I
find it very interesting there's the
Apple Way which is Polish Polish Polish
and don't ship until it's perfect
because you can make it and then there's
the sort of the other approach which is
the sort of incremental hacker mentality
which basically says ship early and
often and iterate and one of the things
I find really interesting is I'm now 30
years into this like
they're a very successful companies on
both sides of that approach right um
like that is a fundamental
difference right in how to operate and
how to build and how to create that you
have world-class companies operating in
both ways
um and I don't think the question of
like which is the superior model is
anywhere close to being answered like
and my suspicion as the answer is do
both the answer is you actually want
both they lead to different outcomes
software tends to do better
um with the iterative approach
um the hardware tends to do better with
the uh you know sort of wait make it
perfect approach but again you can find
examples in in in both directions uh so
the jury's still out on that one uh so
back to Mosaic so what uh
it was text based uh Tim berners-lee
what there was the web which was
text-based but there were no I mean
there was like three websites there was
like no content there were no users like
it wasn't like it wasn't like a
catalytic it had in there by the way it
was all because it was all text there
were no documents there were no images
there were no videos there were no right
so so it was it was and then if in the
beginning if you had to be on a next
cube right you need a hat index Cube
both to publish and to consume so so
there were six thousand bucks you said
there were limitations yeah six thousand
dollar PC they did not they did not sell
very many but then there was also there
was also FTP and there was usenets right
and there was you know a dozen other
basically wait there's waste which was
an early search thing there was gopher
which was an early menu based
information retrieval system there were
like a dozen different sort of scattered
ways that people would get the
information on on the internet and so
the Mosaic idea was basically bring
those all together make the whole thing
graphical make it easy to use make it
basically bulletproof so that anybody
can do it and then again just on the
luck side it so happened that this was
right at the moment when Graphics when
the GUI sort of actually took off and
we're now also used to the GUI that we
think it's been around forever but it
didn't really you know the the Macintosh
brought it out in 85 but they actually
didn't sell very many Max in the 80s it
was not that successful of a product
um it really was when you needed Windows
3.0 on PCS and that hit in about 92.
um and so when we did mosaican 92 93 so
that sort of it was like right at the
moment when you could imagine actually
having a graphical user interface to
right at all much less one to the
internet how uh how old did Windows 3
sell so it was that the really big that
was the Big Bang the big operating
graphical operating system well this is
the classic okay this Microsoft was
operating on the other so Steve Steve
Apple was running on the Polish until
it's perfect Microsoft famously ran on
the other model which is ship and
iterate and so in the Old Line in those
days was Microsoft race version three of
every Microsoft product that's the
that's the good one right so there are
you can you can find online Windows One
windows too nobody used them yeah
actually the original Windows the in the
original Microsoft Windows the windows
were not overlapping
um and so you have these very small very
low resolution screens and then you had
literally um Windows it just didn't work
it wasn't ready yet well in Windows 95 I
think was a pretty big leap also that
was a big leap too yeah so that was like
bang bang
um and then of course Steve and then and
then you know in the fullness of time
Steve came back then the max started
took off again that's the third bang and
then the iPhone was the fourth Bang such
exciting time and then we were afternoon
Off to the Races because nobody could
have known
what would be created from that well
Windows 3.1 or 3.0 Windows 3.0 to the
iPhone was only 15 years
right like it that ramp was in
retrospect at the time it felt like it
took forever but in history in
historical terms like that was a very
fast ramp from even a graphical computer
at all on your desk to the iPhone that
was 15 years did you have a sense of
what the internet will be as you look
into the window of Mosaic like
what like there's just a few web pages
for now
so the thing I had early on was I was
keeping at the time what this disputes
over what was the first blog but I had
one of them that at least is a is a is a
is a possible um at least a runner-up in
the competition um and it was what was
called the what's new page
um uh and it was it was literally it was
hardwired distribution uh unfair
Advantage I've wired put it right in the
browser I put it in the browser and then
I put my resume and the browser which
also it was hilarious but um
I I was keeping the uh not many people
get to get to do that so um no the uh
good good call yeah and early days yes
it's so interesting I'm looking for my
uh about about Oh Marcus looking her job
um so um wow so the West new page I
would literally get up every morning and
I would every afternoon
um and I would basically if you wanted
to launch a website you would email me
um and I would list it on the what's new
page and that was how people discovered
the new websites as they were coming out
and I remember because it was like one
it literally went from it was like one
every couple days to like one every day
and to like to every day
so you're doing it so that that blog was
kind of doing the directory thing so
like what was the home page uh so the
homepage was just basically trying to
explain even what this thing is that
you're looking at right basic basically
basic instructions
um but then there was a button there was
a button that said what's new and what
most people did was they went to
previous reasons went and what's new but
like it was so it was so mind-blowing at
that point just the basic idea and it
was this was like you know this is
basically the internet but people can
see it for the first time the basic idea
was look you know some you know it's
like literally it's like an Indian
restaurant in like Bristol England has
like put their menu on the web and
people were like wow because like that's
the first restaurant menu on the web
yeah and I don't have to be in Bristol
and I don't know if I'm ever gonna go to
Bristol and I don't even like Indian
food and like wow right um and it was
like that uh the first web uh the first
streaming video thing was a uh it was a
another England some expert or something
um some guy uh put uh his coffee pot up
as the first uh streaming uh video thing
and he put it on the web because he
literally coffee pot down the hall yeah
and he wanted to see when he needed to
go uh refill it um but there were you
know there was a point when there were
thousands of people like watching that
coffee pot because it was the first
thing you could watch
but right isn't uh were you able to kind
of infer
you know of that Indian restaurant could
go online then you're like okay oh well
they all will yeah exactly so you felt
that yeah yeah now you know look it's
still a stretch right it's still a
stretch because it's just like okay it's
you know you're still in this Zone which
is like okay is this a nerd thing is
this a real person thing yeah
um by the way we you know there was a
wall a skepticism from the media like
they just like everybody was just like
yeah this is the craziness it's just
like dumb this is not you know this is
not for regular people at that time
um and so you had to think through that
and then look it was still yeah it was
still hard to get on the internet at
that point right so you could get kind
of this weird bastardized version if you
were on AOL which wasn't really real or
you had to go like learn what an ISP was
um you know in those days PCS actually
didn't have TCP drivers come
pre-installed so you had to learn what a
tcpip driver was you had to buy a modem
you had to install driver software
um I have a comedy routine I do
something like 20 minutes long
describing all the steps required to
actually get on the internet at this
point
um and so you had to you had to look
through these practical well and then
and then uh and then speed performance
14 for modems right like it was like
watching you know glue dry
um like and so you had to you had they
were basically a sequence of bets that
we made where you basically needed to
look through that current state of
affairs and say actually there's going
to be so much demand for that once
people figure this out there's gonna be
so much demand for it that all of these
practical problems are going to get
fixed yes some people say that the
anticipation makes the
the destination that much more exciting
do you remember Progressive jpegs yeah
do I do I so forget for kids in the
audience right because you used to have
to watch an image load like a line at a
time but it turns out there was this
thing with jpegs where you could you
could load basically every fourth you
could load like every fourth uh line and
then and then you could sweep back
through again and so you could like
render a fuzzy version image up front
and then it would like resolve into the
detailed one and that was like a big UI
breakthrough because it gave you
something to watch
yeah and uh you know there's
applications in various domains for that
uh
it was a big fight but there was a big
fight early on about whether there
should be images on the web
um for that reason for like
sexualization no not not explicitly that
did come up but it wasn't even that it
was more just like all the serious the
argument went the purists basically said
all the serious information in the world
is text if you introduce images you you
basically going to bring in all the
trivial stuff you're going to bring in
magazines and you know all this crazy I
was just you know stuff that you know
people you know it's going to distract
from that it's going to go take take
away from being serious being frivolous
well was there any uh Doomer type
arguments about uh the internet
destroying all of human civilization or
destroying some fundamental fabric of
human civilization yeah so if those days
it was all around crime and terrorism uh
so those arguments happened um you know
but there was no sense yet of Internet
having like an effect on politics or
because that was that was way too too
far off but um there was an enormous
panic at the time around cyber crime
there was like enormous Panic that like
your credit card number would get stolen
and you'd use life savings to be drained
and then you know criminals were gonna
there was oh um when we started one of
the things we did one of the the
Netscape browser was the first widely
used piece of consumer software that had
strong encryption built in it made it
available to Ordinary People and at that
time strong encryption was actually
illegal to export out of the U.S so we
could field that product in the US we
could not export it because it was it
was classified as ammunition
um so the Netscape browser was on a
restricted list along with the Tomahawk
missile as being something that could
not be exported so we had to make a
second version with deliberately weak
encryption to sell overseas with a big
logo on the box saying do not trust this
which it turns out makes it hard to sell
software uh when it's got a big logo
that says don't trust it
um and then we had to spend five years
fighting the US government to get them
to basically stop trying to do this but
because the fear the fear was terrorists
are going to use encryption right to
like plot you know all these all these
all these things
um and then you know we responded with
well actually we need encryption to be
able to secure systems so the terrorists
and the criminals can't get into them so
that was anyway that was the night that
was the 1990s fight so uh can you say
something about some of the details of
the software engineering challenges
required to build these browsers I mean
the engineering challenges of creating a
product that hasn't really existed
before
that can have such uh almost like
Limitless uh impact on the world with
the internet so there was a really key
bet that we made at the time which is
very controversial which was core to
core to how it was engineered which was
are we optimizing for performance or for
ease of creation yeah and in those days
the pressure was very intense to
optimize for performance because the
network connections were so slow and
also the computers were so slow
um and so if you had you know I
mentioned the progressive jpegs like
if if there's an alternate World in
which we optimize for performance and it
just you had just a much more pleasant
experience right up front
but what we got by not doing that was we
got ease of creation and the way that we
got ease of creation was all of the
protocols and formats were in text not
in binary and so HTTP isn't text by the
way and this was an internet tradition
by the way that we picked up but we
continued at HTTP is taxed and HTML is
taxed and then everybody else everything
else that followed his text as a result
and by the way you can imagine purist
Engineers saying this is insane you have
very limited bandwidth why are you
wasting any time sending text you should
be encoding the stuff into binary and
it'll be much faster of course the
answer is that's correct but what you
get when you make it text is all of a
sudden well the big breakthrough was the
view Source function right so the fact
that you could look at a web page you
could hit view source and you could see
the HTML that was how people learn how
to make web pages right it's so
interesting because the stuff would take
for granted now
is uh man that was fundamental to the
development of the web to be able to
have HTML just right there all the
ghetto mess that is HTML all the sort of
almost biological like messiness of HTML
and then having the browser tried to
interpret that mess yeah to show
something reasonable well and then there
was this internet principle that we
inherited which was emit what was it
emit cautiously emit conservatively
interpret liberally so it basically
meant if you're in the design principle
was if you're if you're creating like a
web editor that's going to admit HTML
like do it as cleanly as you can but you
actually want the browser to interpret
liberally which is you actually want
users to be able to make all kinds of
mistakes and for it to still work yeah
and so the browser rendering engines to
this day have all of this spaghetti code
crazy stuff where they can they're
resilient to all kinds of crazy HTML
mistakes and so and literally what I
always had in my head is like there's an
eight-year-old or an 11 year old
somewhere and they're doing a view
Source they're doing a cut and paste and
they're trying to make a web page for
their turtle or whatever and like they
leave out a slash and they leave out an
angle bracket and they do this they do
that and it still works it's it's also
like that I don't often think about this
but you know programming you know C plus
plus CC plus plus all those languages
list but the compiled language the
interpreted language is python Pearl all
that they the brace have to be all
correct yes like everything has to be
perfect brutal
and then autistic you forget all right
it's systematic and rigorous let's go
there but you forget that the uh uh the
web with JavaScript eventually uh and
HTML is allowed to be messy in the way
for the first time
Messi in the way biological systems
could be messy it's like the only thing
computers were allowed to be messy on
for the first time it used to offend me
so I I grew up in units I I worked on
Unix I was a Unix native for all the way
through this period um and so and it
used to drive me bananas when it would
do the the segmentation fault and the
chord on file and just like it's you
know it's like literally there's like an
error in the code the math is off by one
yeah and it core dumps yeah and I'm in
the core dump trying to analyze it and
trying to reconstruct what and I'm just
like this is ridiculous like the
computer ought to be smart enough to be
able to know that if it's off by one
okay fine and it keeps running and I
would go ask all the experts like why
can't I just keep running and they'd
explain to me well because all the
downstream repercussions blah blah and
I'm like they're still like you know
this is if we're forcing the human
Creator to live to your point in this
hyper little literal world of perfection
yeah and I was just like that's just
that's just bad and by the way you know
because what happens with that of course
is what happened with with coding at
that point which is you get a high
priesthood you know there's a small
number of people who are really good at
doing exactly that most people can't and
most people are excluded from it and so
actually that was where that for there's
where I picked up that idea was um uh
was like no no you want you want you
want these things to be resilient to
error in all kinds and this this would
drive the purest absolutely crazy like I
got attacked on this like a lot because
yeah I mean like every time I you know
all the purists who were like into all
this like markup language stuff and
formats and codes and all the stuff they
would be like you know you can't you're
encouraging bad behavior because oh so
they wanted the browser to give you an a
sec fault error at any time there was uh
yeah yeah they wanted it to be a cop
right they wanted yeah that was a very
and any any properly trained credential
engineer would be like that's not how
you build these systems that's such a
bold move to say no it doesn't have to
be yeah now like I said the good news
for me is the internet kind of had that
traditional already
um but we but having said that like we
pushed it we pushed it way out but the
other thing we did going back to the
performance thing was we gave up a lot
of performance we made that initial
experience for the first few years was
pretty painful but but the bet there was
actually an economic bet which was
basically the demand for the web would
basically mean that there would be a
surge in supply of broadband like we
because the question was okay how do you
get how do you how do you get the phone
companies which are not famous in those
days for doing new things at huge cost
for like speculative reasons like how do
you get them to build up Broadband you
know spend billions of dollars doing
that and you know you could go meet with
them and try to talk them into it or you
could just have a thing where it's just
very clear that it's going to be the
people love that's going to be better if
it's faster and so that that there was a
period there and this was this was
fraught with some Peril but there was a
period there where it's like we knew the
experience was sub-optimized because we
were trying to force the emergence of
demand for Broadband sure which is in
fact what happened
so you have to figure out how to display
this text html text
so the Blue Links and the purple links
and there's no standards is there
standards at that time it really still
wasn't
well there's like there's implied
implied standards right and they you
know there's all these cousin new
features that are being added like CSS
what like what kind of stuff a browser
should be able to support features
within languages within JavaScript and
so on but you you bait you're setting
standards
on the fly yeah yourself well to this
day if you if you create a web page that
has no CSS style sheet the browser will
render it however it wants to yeah right
so this was one of the things there was
this idea this idea at the time and how
these systems were built which is
separation of content from uh format or
separation of uh yeah content from
appearance
um and that's still people don't really
use it anymore because everybody wants
to determine how things look and so they
use CSS but um it's still in there that
you can just let the browser do all the
work I still like the
like uh really basic websites but that
could be just old school kids these days
with their fancy
responsive websites that don't actually
have much content but have a lot of
visual elements well that's one of the
things that's fun about chat you know
about chatgpt yes like back to the
basics back to just text yeah right and
it you know there is this pattern in
human creativity and media where you end
up back at text and I think there's you
know there's something powerful in there
is there some other stuff you remember
like the purple links there were some
interesting design decisions to kind of
come up that we have today or we don't
have today that were temporary so uh we
made I made the background I hated
reading text on white uh uh backgrounds
and so I made the background for
everybody
no no no that's that decision I think
has been reversed um but but now I'm
happy though because now dark mode is
the thing so so it wasn't about gray it
was just he didn't want white background
strain my eyes
change your eyes interesting
um and then there's a bunch of other
decisions I'm sure there's an
interesting history of the development
of HTML and CSS and all those and
interface and JavaScript and there's
this whole Java applet thing
well the big one probably JavaScript CSS
was after me so I didn't that was not me
but um JavaScript was the big JavaScript
maybe was the biggest of the whole thing
that was us
um and um and that was basically a bet
it was a bet on two things one is that
the world wanted a new front-end
scripting language
um and then the other was we I thought
at the time the world wanted a new
back-end scripting language
um so JavaScript was designed from the
beginning to be both front end and back
end
and then it failed as a back-end
scripting language and uh Java one for a
long time and then python Pearl and
other things PHP um and Ruby but now
JavaScript is back and so I wonder if
everything in the end will run on
JavaScript it see it seems like it is
the um and by the way let me give a
shout out to uh to um uh uh Brendan Ike
uh was the uh basically the one-man
inventor of um of JavaScript if you're
interested to learn more about Brandon
Knights podcast previously exactly so he
wrote JavaScript over a summer um and it
I I mean I think it is fair it is fair
to say now that it's the most widely
used language in the world and it seems
to only be gaining in in um in its uh in
its range of adoption in the software
world there's quite a few stories of
somebody over a weekend or over a week
or over a summer writing some of the
most uh impactful revolutionary pieces
of software ever well look that should
be inspiring yes very inspiring I'll
give you another one SSL
um so SSL was the security protocol that
was us and that was a crazy idea at the
time which was let's take all the native
protocols and let's wrap them in a
security rapper that was a guy named Kip
Hickman who wrote that over a summer uh
one guy
um and then look today sitting here
today like the transformer like at
Google there's a small handful of people
and then you know the number of people
who have did like the core work on GPT
it's not that many people it's a pretty
small handful of people
um and so yeah the pattern in software
repeatedly over a very long time has
been it's it's a Jeff Jeff Bezos always
said the two Pizza rule uh for teams at
Amazon which is any team needs to be
able to be fed with two pieces if you
need the third Pizza you have too many
people and I I think that's I think
that's I think it's actually the one
pizza rule yeah for the for the really
creative work I think it's two people
three people well that's you see that
with certain open source projects like
so much is done by like one or two
people like it's it's so incredible and
that's why you see that gives me so much
hope about
the open source movement in this new age
of AI where
um you know just recently haven't had a
conversation with with Mark Zuckerberg
of all people who's all in on open
source which is so interesting to see
and so inspiring to see because like
releasing these models it is scary it is
potentially very dangerous and we'll
talk about that
but it's also
if you believe in the goodness of most
people and in the skill set of most
people and the desire to do good in the
world that's really exciting because
it's not putting it these models into
the centralized control of big
corporations the government and so on
it's putting it in the in the hands of a
teen teenage kid with like a dream in
his eyes I don't know that's um
that's beautiful and look this stuff AI
ought to make the individual coder
obviously far more productive right by
like you know a thousand X or something
and so you ought to be open source like
the not just the future of Open Source
yeah but the future of Open Source
everything we ought to have a world now
of super coders right who are building
things yeah as open source with one or
two people that were inconceivable you
know five years ago
um you know the level of kind of hyper
productivity we're going to get out of
our best and brightest I think is going
to go way up it's gonna be interesting
we'll talk about it but let's just uh
linger a little bit on Netscape
that skip was acquired in 1999 for 4.3
billion by AOL what was that uh what was
that like what was what were some
memorable aspects of that well that was
the height of the.com Boom bubble bust I
mean that was the that was the frenzy um
if you watched a succession that was the
that was like what they did in the
fourth season with uh with kojo and the
merger with the with their so it was
like the height of like one of those
kind of Dynamics and so would you
recommend succession by the way I'm more
of a Yellowstone guy he almost sounds
very American I'm I'm very proud of you
that is I just talked to Matthew
McConaughey and I'm full on Texan at
this point good I heartily approve um
and uh he will be doing the sequel to
the Yellowstone very exciting anyway
okay wait uh so that's a rude
Interruption by Me by way of succession
uh so that was at the height of the deal
making and money and just the fur flying
and like craziness and so yeah it was
just one of those it was just like I
mean there's the entire nescape thing
from start to finish was four years
um which was like for one of these
companies it's just like incredibly fast
you know it we went public 18 months
after we got moved we were founded which
virtually never happens so it was just
this incredibly fast kind of meteor
streaking across the sky
um and then of course it was this and
then there was just this explosion right
that happened because then it was almost
immediately followed by the.com Crash It
Was Then followed by AOL by Time Warner
which again is the succession guys kind
of play with that uh which turned out to
be a disastrous deal um you know one of
the famous you know kind of disasters in
business history
um and then um and then you know what
became an internet depression on the
other side of that but then in that
depression in the 2000s was the
beginning of broadband and smartphones
and Web 2.0 right and then social media
and search and every SAS and everything
that came out of that so what did you
learn from just the acquisition I mean
this is so much money
what's interesting because I I must have
been very new to you that these software
stuff you can make so much money there's
so much money swimming around I mean I'm
sure the ideas of investment were
starting to get born there yes let me
get so let me lay it so here's here's
the thing I don't know if I figured out
then but figured out later which is
um software is a technology that it's
like a you know the concept of the
Philosopher's Stone this is a
philosopher stone in alchemy
transmission led into gold and Newton
spent 20 years trying to find the
Philosopher's Stone never got there
nobody's ever figured it out software is
our modern philosopher stone and in
economic uh terms it transmutes labor
into capital
which is like a super interesting thing
and by the way like Karl Marx is rolling
over and describe right now because of
course that's a complete refutation of
his entire Theory um
transmission labor and capital which is
which is as follows is somebody sits
down on a keyboard and types A bunch of
stuff in and a capital asset comes out
the other side and then somebody buys
that Capital asset for a billion dollars
like
that's amazing right it's literally
creating value right out of thin air
right out of purely human thought right
um and so that that that's there are
many things that make software magical
and special but that's the economics I
wonder what Marx would have thought
about that oh he would have completely
broke his brain because of course the
whole the whole thing was he was you
could he you know that kind of
technology is inconceivable when he was
alive it was all it was all industrial
Hera stuff and so the any kind of
Machinery necessarily involves huge
amounts of capital and then labor was on
the on the receiving end of the abuse
yeah
um right but like software software a
software engineer is somebody who
basically transmutes his own labor into
action a national capital asset
um creates permanent value well in fact
it's actually very inspiring um that's
actually more true today than before so
when I was doing software the Assumption
was all new software basically has a
sort of a parabolic sort of life cycle
right so you you ship the thing people
buy it at some point everybody who wants
it has bought it and then it becomes
Obsolete and it's like bananas nobody
nobody buys old software
um these days um Minecraft
um Mathematica you know Facebook Google
um you have the software assets that are
you know have been around for 30 years
that are gaining in value every year
right and they're just there being a
World of Warcraft right salesforce.com
like they're being every single year
they're being polished and Polished and
Polished and Polished they're getting
better and better more powerful more
powerful more valuable more valuable so
we've entered this era where you can
actually have these things that actually
build out over decades which by the way
is what's happening right now with like
GPT
um and so um now and this is why you
know there there is always you know sort
of a constant investment frenzy around
software is because you know look when
you start one of these things it doesn't
always succeed but when it does now you
might be building an asset that builds
value for you know four or five six
decades to come
um you know if you have a team of people
who have the level of devotion required
to keep making it better
and then the fact that of course
everybody's online you know there's five
billion people that are a click away
from any new piece of software so the
potential Market size for any of these
things is you know nearly infinite it
must have been surreal back then though
yeah yeah this was all brand new right
yeah back then this was all brand new
these were all you know brand new had
you rolled out that theory in in even
1999 people would have thought you were
smoking crack so that's that's emerged
over time
well let's uh now turn back into the
future you wrote the s-a-y-a-i will save
the world
let's start the very high level what's
the main thesis of the essay yeah so the
main thesis on the essay is that what
we're dealing with here is intelligence
um and it's really important to kind of
talk about the sort of very nature of
what intelligence is and
fortunately we have a we have a
predecessor to machine intelligence
which is human intelligence and we've
got you know observations and theories
over thousands of years for what what
what intelligence is in the hands of
humans and what intelligence is right I
mean what it literally is is the way to
uh you know capture process analyze
synthesize information solve problems
um but the observation of of
intelligence in human hands is that
intelligence quite literally makes
everything better
um and what I mean by that is every kind
of outcome of like human quality of life
whether it's education outcomes or
success of your children
for a Career Success or health or
lifetime satisfaction
um by the way
propensity to peacefulness as opposed to
violence uh propensity for
open-mindedness versus bigotry those are
all associated with higher levels of
intelligence smarter people have better
outcomes than almost as you write you
know every domain of activity academic
achievement job performance occupational
status income creativity physical health
longevity learning new skills managing
complex tasks leadership entrepreneurial
success conflict resolution reading
comprehension financial decision making
understanding how this perspectives
creative arts parenting outcomes and
life satisfaction one of the
more depressing conversations I've had
and I don't know why it's depressing I
have to really think through wise
depressing but on IQ
and uh the G Factor
and that that's something in large part
is genetic
and it correlates so much with all of
these things and success in life
it's like all the inspirational stuff we
read about like if you work hard and so
on
damn it sucks that you're born with the
hand that you can't change but what if
you could you're saying basically a
really important point I think it's a uh
in your articles
it really helped me
um
it's a nice added perspective to think
about listen human intelligence the
science of intelligence is shown
scientifically that it just makes life
easier and better
the smarter you are and now let's look
at artificial intelligence
and
if uh that's a way to increase the the
some human intelligence then it's only
going to make a better life yeah that's
the argument and certainly at the
collective level we could talk about the
collective effect of just having more
intelligence in the world which which
will have very big payoff but there's
also just at the individual level like
what if every person has a machine you
know and it's a concept of augment Doug
engelbert's concept of augmentation
um you know what if everybody has a an
assistant and the assistant is you know
140 IQ
um and you happen to be 110 IQ
um and you've got you know something
that basically is infinitely patient and
knows everything about you and is
pulling for you in every possible way
wants you to be successful and anytime
you find anything confusing or want to
learn anything or have trouble
understanding something or want to
figure out what to do in a situation
right I'm going to figure out how to
prepare for a job interview like any of
these things like it will help you do it
and it will therefore the combination
will effectively be you know well if you
effectively raise your raise because it
will effectively raise your IQ will
therefore raise the odds of successful
life outcomes in all these areas so
people below the this hypothetical 140
IQ it'll pull them up towards 140 IQ
yeah yeah and then of course you know
people at people at 140 IQ will be able
to have a peer right to be able to
communicate which is great and then
people above 140 IQ will have an
assistance if they can Farm things out
to and then look God willing you know at
some point these things go from future
versions go from 140 IQ equivalent to
150 to 160 to 180 right like Einstein
was the estimated to be on the order of
160.
um you know so when we get you know 160
AI like will be you know when one
assumes creating Einstein level
breakthroughs and physics and and then
and then at 180 we'll be you know curing
cancer and developing warp drive and
doing all kinds of stuff and so it is
quite possibly the case this is the most
important thing that's ever happened the
best things ever happen because
precisely because it's a lever on this
single fundamental factor of
intelligence which is the thing that
drives so much of everything else
can you still man the case that human
plus AI is not always better than human
for the individual you may have noticed
that there's a lot of smart assholes
running around sure yes right and so
like it's smart there are certain people
where they get smarter you know they get
to be more arrogant right so you know
there's one huge flaw although to push
back on that it might be interesting
because when the intelligence is not all
coming from you but from a system from
another system that might actually
increase the the amount of humility even
in the assholes one would hope
um or it could make assholes more
assholes you know that's I mean that's
that's for psychology to study yeah
exactly another one is um the smart
people are very convinced that they you
know have a more rational view of the
world and that they have a easier time
seeing through conspiracy theories and
hoaxes and right you know sort of crazy
beliefs and all that there's a theory in
Psychology which is actually smart
people so for sure people who aren't as
smart are very susceptible to hoaxes and
conspiracy theories but it may also be
the case that the smarter you get you
become susceptible in a different way uh
which is you become very good at
marshalling facts to fit preconceptions
right
um you become very very good at
assembling whatever theories and
Frameworks and pieces of data and graphs
and charts you need to validate whatever
crazy idea has got in your head and so
you're susceptible in a different way
right uh we're all sheep but
different colored some sheep are better
at justifying it right
um and those are the you know those are
the smart shape right
um so yeah look like it I would say this
look like there are no fantasy I'm not
I'm not a utopian there are no panaceas
in life um there are no like you know I
don't believe they're like pure
positives I'm not a transcendental kind
of person like that but you know so yeah
there are going to be issues
um uh and um and you know look smart
people another maybe you could say about
smart people is they are more likely to
get themselves in situations that are
you know beyond their grasp you know
because they're just more confident that
their ability to deal with complexity
and their their eyes become bigger their
cognitive eyes become bigger than their
stomach you know so yeah you could argue
those eight different ways nevertheless
on that right clearly overwhelmingly
again if you just extrapolate from what
we know about human intelligence you're
you're improving so many aspects of life
if you're upgrading intelligence
so there'll be assistance at all stages
of life so when you're younger there's
for Education all that kind of stuff or
mentorship all of this and uh later on
as you're doing work and you've
developed a skill and you're having a
profession you'll have an assistant that
helps you excel at that profession so at
all stages of Life yeah I mean look the
theory is augmentations this is the
gecko Birds term for the technical part
made the subservation many many decades
ago that you know basically it's like
you can have this oppositional frame of
Technology where it's like us versus the
machines but what you really do is you
use technology to augment human
capabilities yeah and by the way that's
how actually the economy develops that's
we can talk about the economic side of
this but that's actually how the economy
grows is through technology augmenting
human human potential
um and so yeah and then you basically
have a proxy or a you know or or a a um
you know a sort of prosthetic um you
know so like you've got glasses you've
got a wristwatch you know you've got
shoes you know you've got these things
you've got a personal computer you've
got a word processor you've got
Mathematica you've got Google this is
the latest viewed through that lens the
AI is the latest in a long series of
basically augmentation methods uh to be
able to raise human capabilities it's
just this one is the most powerful one
of all because this is the one that goes
directly to but what they call fluid
intelligence which is IQ
well there's uh two categories of folks
that you outline that uh that worry
about or highlight the risks of AI and
you highlight a bunch of different risks
I would love to go through those risks
and just discuss some brainstorm
which ones are serious and which ones
are less serious but first the Baptist
and the Bootleggers what are these two
interesting groups of folks
who are who who worry about uh the
effect of AI and human civilization or
say they do say okay yes I'll say they
do the Baptist Warrior the Bootleggers
say they do yeah
um so the Baptist and the Bootleggers is
a metaphor from economics um from what's
called development economics and it's
this observation that when you get
social reform movements
um in a society you tend to get two sets
of people showing up arguing for the
social reform um and the the term
baptism Bootleggers comes from the
American experience with alcohol
prohibition
um and so in the 1900s 1910s there was
this movement that was very passionate
at the time which basically said alcohol
is the evil and it's destroying Society
by the way there was a lot of evidence
to support this
um there were very high rates of very
high correlations then by the way and
now between race of physical violence
and alcohol use almost all violent
crimes have either the perpetrator or
the victim are both drunk almost all if
you see this actually in the work almost
all social harassment cases the
workplace it's like at a company party
and somebody's drunk like it's it's
amazing how often alcohol actually
correlates to actually just dysfunction
at least two domestic abuse and so forth
child abuse and so you had this group of
people who were like okay this this is
bad stuff and we should Outlaw it and
those were quite literally Baptists
those were super committed you know
hardcore Christian activists in a lot of
cases there was this woman uh whose name
was Carrie Nation
um who was this older woman who had been
in this you know I don't know disastrous
marriage or something and her husband
had been abusive and drunk all the time
and she became the icon of the Baptist
uh prohibitionist and she was legendary
in that era for carrying an ax
um and doing you know completely on her
own doing raids of saloons and like
picking her ax to all the bottles and
things in the back and and so so a True
Believer an absolute True Believer
um and with absolutely the purest of
intentions and again
there's a very important thing here it
which is there's you could look at this
cynically and you could say the Baptists
are like delusional you know extremists
but you could also say look they're
right like she was maybe you know she
had a point like she wasn't wrong
um about a lot of what she said yeah but
it turns out the way The Story Goes is
it turns out that there were another set
of people who very badly wanted to
outlaw alcohol in those days and those
were the Bootleggers which was organized
crime this stood to make a huge amount
of money if legal alcohol sales were
banned and this was in fact the way the
history goes is this was actually the
beginning of organized crime in the U.S
this was the big Economic Opportunity
that opened that up
um and so they went in together
um and then they didn't go in together
like the Baptist did not even
necessarily know about the Bootleggers
because they were on their moral Crusade
The Bootlegger certainly knew about the
Baptists and they were like wow this is
these people are like the great front
people for like you know it's good PR
Shenanigans in the background yeah and
they got the Volstead Act passed right
and they did in fact ban alcohol in the
U.S and you'll notice what happened
which is people kept drinking like it
didn't work and people kept drinking
um the Bootleggers made a tremendous
amount of money um and then over time it
became clear that it made no sense to
make it illegal and it was causing more
problems and so then it was revoked and
here we sit with legal alcohol 100 years
later with all the same problems
um and you know the whole thing was this
like giant misadventure uh the Baptist
got taken advantage of by the
bootleggers and the Bootleggers got what
they wanted and and that was that the
same two categories of folks are now uh
sort of suggesting that uh the
development of artificial intelligence
should be regulated 100 yeah it's the
same pattern and the the economists the
same pattern every time like this is
what happened with nuclear power this is
what happened which is another
interesting one but like yeah this is
this happens dozens and dozens of times
um throughout the last hundred years and
and this is what's happening now and you
write that it isn't sufficient to Simply
identify the actors and impugn their
motives we should consider the arguments
of both the Baptists and the Bootleggers
on their merits so let's do just that
risk number one
uh will AI kill us all yes
so
uh what do you think about this one this
this what do you think is the core
argument here
that uh the development of AGI perhaps
but I said uh will destroy human
civilization no first of all you just
did a sleight of hand because we went
from talking about AI to AGI
is there a fundamental difference there
I don't know what's AGI uh what's AI
what's inside I know what AI is AI is
machine learning
I think we don't know what the bottom of
the well of machine learning is or what
the ceiling is right because just uh to
call something machine learning or just
to call some of the statistics or just
to call it math or computation doesn't
mean you know uh nuclear weapons are
just physics so it's it it's to me it's
very interesting and surprising how far
machine learning no but we knew that
nuclear physics would lead to weapons
that's why the scientists of that era
were always in this huge dispute about
building the weapons this is different
ages different as machine learningly do
we know we don't know but this is my
point it's different we actually don't
know but and this is where you the
sleight of hand kicks in right this is
where it goes from being a scientific
topic to being a religious topic
um and that's that's why I specifically
called out that because that's what
happens they do the vocabulary shift and
all of a sudden you're talking about
something totally that's not actually
real well then maybe you could also uh
as part of that Define the Western
tradition of millennialism yes end of
the world apocalypse apocalypse Cults um
well so we live in we of course live in
a judeo Christian but primarily
Christian kind of saturated you know
kind of Christian post-christian
secularized Christian you know kind of
world in the west
um and of course Court of Christianity
is the idea of the second coming and and
you know the revelations and you know
Jesus returning and thought the
Thousand-Year you know Utopia on Earth
and then the you know the Rapture and
like all stuff you know we don't we you
know we collectively you know as a
society we don't necessarily take all
that fully seriously now so what we do
is we create our secularized versions of
that we keep we keep looking for Utopia
we keep looking for you know basically
the end of the world and so what you see
over over decades is basically a pattern
of these sort of of these of these of is
this this is what calls are this is how
Cults form as they form around some
theory of the end of the world and so
the people's Temple calls the Manson
called the heavens gate called the David
koresh called it you know what they're
all organized around is like there's
going to be this thing that's going to
happen that's going to basically bring
civilization crashing down and then we
have this special Elite group of people
who are going to see it coming and
prepare for it and then they're the
people who are either going to stop it
or are failing stopping it they're going
to be the people who survive to the
other side and ultimately get credit for
having been right why is that so
compelling do you think like uh because
it satisfies this very deep need we have
for Transcendence and meaning
that got Stripped Away when we became
secular yeah but why is the
Transcendence involved the destruction
of human civilization because like how
like how plausible it's it's like a very
deep psychological thing because it's
like how plausible how plausible is it
that we live in a world where
everything's just kind of all right
how exciting is that right but that's
more than that but that's the Deep
question I'm asking why is it not
exciting to live in a world where
everything's just all right does it I
think uh you know most of the animal
kingdom would be so happy we just all
right yeah because that means survival
why are we uh maybe that's what it is
why are we Conjuring up things to worry
about so C.S Lewis called it the
god-shaped hole so there's a god-shaped
hole in The Human Experience
Consciousness Soul whatever you want to
call it where there's got to be
something that's bigger than all this
there's got to be something Transcendent
there's got to be something that is
bigger right bigger the bigger purpose a
bigger meaning
and so we have run the experiment of you
know we're just going to use science and
rationality and kind of you know
everything's just going to kind of be as
it appears and a large number of people
have found that very deeply wanting and
have constructed narratives and by the
way this is the story of the 20th
century right communism right was one of
those communism was a was a form of this
Nazism was a form of this
um you know some people um you know you
can see movements like this playing out
all over the world right now so you
could start the kind of devil a kind of
source of evil and we're going to
transcend Beyond it yeah and the
millinarians the Millionaire's kind of
when you see a millionaire and cult they
put a really specific point on it which
is end of the world right there there is
some change coming and that change
that's coming is so profound and so
important that it's either going to lead
to Utopia or hell on Earth right
um and it is going to and then you know
it's like what if you actually knew that
that was going to happen right what
would you what what would you do right
how would you prepare yourself for it
how would you come together with a group
of like-minded people right how would
you what would you do would you plan
like caches of weapons in the woods
would you like you know I don't know if
it's create under underground bunkers
would you you know spend your life
trying to figure out a way to avoid
having it happen yeah that's a really
compelling exciting idea to uh to have a
club over to have to have a to have a
little bit of trial like a get together
on a Saturday night and drink some beers
and talk about the the end of the world
and how are you you are the only ones
who have figured it out yeah and then
and then once you lock in on that like
how can you do anything else with your
life like this is obviously the thing
that you have to do and then and then
there's a psychological effect you
alluded to there's a psychological
effect if you take a set of True
Believers and you leave them to
themselves they get more radical right
because they self-radicalize each other
that said yes it doesn't mean they're
not sometimes right yeah at the end of
the world might be yes correct like they
might be right yeah but like we have
some pamphlets for you
I mean there's I mean we'll talk about
nuclear weapons because if you have a
really interesting little moment that I
learned about in in your essay but you
know sometimes it could be right yeah
yeah because we're still you were
developing more and more powerful
Technologies uh in this case and we
don't know what the impact they will
have on human civilization well we can
highlight all the different predictions
about how it will be positive but the
risks are there
and you discuss some of them well the
Steel Man the steel man is the Steel Man
actually the steel man and his
refutation are the same which is you
can't predict what's going to happen
right you right you can't rule out that
this will not end everything right but
the response to that is you have just
made a completely non-scientific claim
yeah you've made a religious claim not a
scientific claim how does it get
disproven there is and there's no by
definition with these kinds of claims
there's no way to disprove them yeah
right um and so there's no you just go
right on the list there's no hypothesis
there's no testability of the hypothesis
there's no um way to falsify the
hypothesis there's no way to measure
progress along the arc like it's just
all completely missing and so it's not
scientific and well I don't think it's
completely missing it's it's somewhat
missing so for example the the the the
people that say AI is going to kill all
of us
I mean they usually have ideas about how
to do that whether it's the paperclip
maximizer or um you know it escapes
there's mechanism by which you can
imagine it killing all humans models and
to you can disprove it by saying there
is um
there's a limit
to uh the speed at which intelligence
increases
maybe show that uh
like the sort of rigorously really
described model like how it could happen
and say no there here's a physics
limitation there's a physical limitation
to how these systems would actually
damaging human civilization and it is
possible they will kill 10 to 20 percent
of the population but it seems
impossible for them to kill uh 99
there's practical counter arguments
right so you mentioned basically what I
described as the thermodynamic counter
argument which is sitting here today
it's like we're with the evil AGI gets
the gpus yeah because like they don't
exist so you're gonna have a very
frustrated baby evil AGI who's going to
be like trying to buy Nvidia stock or
something to get them to finally make
some chips um right so the the serious
form of that is the thermodynamic
argument which is like okay where's the
energy going to come from where's the
processor going to be running where is
the data center going to be happening
how is this going to be happening in
Secrets such that you know it's not you
know so so that's a practical counter
argument to The Runaway AGI I think I
have a but I have a and we can argue
that discuss that I have a deeper
objection to it which is it's this is
all forecasting it's all modeling it's
all it's all future prediction it's all
future hypothesizing it's not science
sure it is not it is it is the opposite
of science so the Carl Sagan
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary proof right these are
extraordinary claims the policies that
are being called for right to prevent
this are of extraordinary magnitude and
I think we're going to cause
extraordinary damage and this is all
being done on the basis of something
that is literally not scientific it's
not a testable hypothesis so the moment
you say AI is going to kill all of us
therefore we should ban it or that we
should regulate all that kind of that's
when it starts getting serious or start
you know military airstrikes and data
centers oh boy right
and like
yeah this one is get starts well so it
starts getting real so here's the
problem of millionaire and Cults they
have a hard time staying away from
violence
HIPAA violence is so fun
if you're on the right end of it they
have a hard time avoiding balance the
reason I have a hard time affording
balance is if you actually believe the
claim right then what would you do to
stop the end of the world well you would
do anything right yeah and so and this
is where you get I mean again if you
just look at the history of millionaire
and Cults this is where you get the
people's Temple and everybody killing
themselves in the jungle and this is
where you get Charles Manson and you
know sending in need to kill kill the
pigs like this is the problem with these
they have a very hard time to run the
line at actual violence and I think I
think in this case there's there I mean
they're already calling for it like
today and you know where this goes from
here is they get more worked up like I
think it's like really concerning okay
but that's kind of the extreme so you
know the extremes of anything I was
concerning
it's also possible to kind of believe
that AI has a very high likelihood of
killing all of us
uh but there's and therefore we should
uh maybe consider
uh slowing development or regulating so
not violence or any of these kinds of
things but it's saying like all right
let's let's take a pause here you know
your biological weapons nuclear weapons
like
this is like serious stuff we should be
careful so it is possible to kind of
have a more rational response right if
you believe this risk is real believe
yes so what is it possible to be have a
scientific approach to the the
prediction of the future I mean we just
went through this with covet yeah what
do we know about modeling
well I mean what do we learn about
modeling with covet uh there's a lot of
lessons they didn't work at all
they worked poorly the models were
terrible the models were useless I don't
know if the models were useless or the
people interpreting the models and then
the centralized institutions that were
creating policy rapidly based on the
models and leveraging the models in
order to support their narratives versus
actually interpreting the error bars and
the bottles and all that kind of stuff
what you had with my view you had with
confidence you have these experts
showing up and they claim to be
scientists and they had no testable
hypotheses whatsoever they had a bunch
of models they had a bunch of forecasts
and they had a bunch of theories and
they laid these out in front of policy
makers and policymakers freaked out and
panicked right and implemented a whole
bunch of like really like terrible
decisions that were still living with
the consequences of
um and there was never any empirical
Foundation to any of the models none of
them ever came true yeah to push to push
back they were certainly Baptists and
Bootleggers in this in the context of
this pandemic but there's still a
usefulness to models no I I so not if
they're I mean not if they're reliably
wrong right then they're actually like
anti-useful right they're actually
damaging but what do you do with a pen
endemic what do you do with the were
they at with any kind of threat don't
you want to kind of have um several
models to play with as part of the
discussion of like what the hell do we
do here I mean do they work
because they're an expectation that they
actually like work that they have actual
predictive value
I mean as far as I can tell with covet
we just saw the policy makers just Psy
up themselves into believing that there
was I mean look the scientists the
scientists were at fault this is the
quote unquote scientists showed up so I
had some insight into this so there was
a remember the Imperial College models
out of London were the ones that were
like these are the gold standard models
yeah so a friend of mine runs a big
software company and he was like wow
this is like hope it's really scary and
he's like you know he contacted This
research and he's like you know do you
need some help you've been just building
this model on your own for 20 years do
you need some who did you like our
coders to basically restructure it so it
can be fully adapted for covet and the
guy said yes and sent over the code and
my friend said it was like the worst
spaghetti code he's ever seen that
doesn't mean it's not possible to
construct a good model of pandemic with
the correct error bars with a high
number of parameters that are
continuously many times a day updated as
we give more data about a pandemic I
would like to believe when a pandemic
hits the world the best computer
scientist in the world the best software
Engineers respond aggressively and as
input take the data that we know about
the virus and put say here is here's
what's happening in terms of how quickly
it's spreading what that lead in terms
of hospitalization and deaths and all
that kind of stuff here's How likely how
contagious it likely is here's how
deadly likely is based on different
conditions based on different ages and
demographics and all that kind of stuff
so here's the best kinds of policy it
feels like you could have models
machine learning that like kind of they
don't perfectly predict the future but
they they help you do something because
there's pandemics that are like
uh
meh they don't really do much harm and
there's pandemics you can imagine them
they could do a huge amount of harm like
they can kill a lot of people so you
should probably have some kind of data
driven models that keep updating that
allow you to make decisions on base like
where how bad is this thing uh now you
can criticize
how horrible all that went with the
response to this pandemic but I just
feel like there might be some value to
models so to be useful at some point it
has to be predictive right so and so and
and so the easy thing for me to do is to
say obviously you're right obviously I
want to see that just as much as you do
because anything that makes it easier to
navigate through Society through a
wrenching you know risk like that is you
know that sounds great um you know the
the harder objection to it is just
simply you are trying to model a complex
dynamic system with eight billion moving
Parts like not possible very tough can't
be done complex systems can't be done uh
machine learning says hold my beer but
well it's possible no I don't know I
would like to believe that it is yeah
put it this way I think where you and I
would agree is I think we would like we
would like that to be the case we are
strongly in favor of it I think we would
also agree that no such thing with
respect to covet or pandemics no such
thing at least neither you nor I think
or where I'm not aware of anything like
that today my main worry with the
response to the pandemic is that uh uh
same as with aliens is that even if such
a thing existed and it's possible it
existed
the the the the policy makers we're not
paying attention like uh there was no
mechanism that allowed those kinds of
models to percolate up oh I think we
have the opposite problem during covet I
think the policymakers I think the these
these these people with basically fake
science had too much access to the
policymakers
well right and what but the policy
makers also wanted they had a narrative
in mind and they also wanted to use
whatever model that fit that narrative
to help them out so like it felt like
there was a lot of politics and not
enough science yeah although a big part
of what was happening a big reason we
got lockdowns for as long as we did was
because these scientists came in with
these like Doomsday scenarios that were
like just like completely off the hook
scientists and quotes that's not
quote-unquote that's not okay let's give
love so here's science that is the way
out science is a process of testing
hypotheses yeah modeling does not
involve testable hypotheses right like I
don't even know that my I actually don't
I didn't even know that modeling
actually qualifies in science
maybe that's a side conversation we
could have some time over a beer uh it's
a really interesting but what do we do
about the future I mean what what so
number one is when we start with number
one humility it goes back to this thing
of how do we determine the truth number
two is we don't believe you know it's
the old I've got a hammer everything
looks like a nail right
um I've got oh uh it's one of the
reasons I gave you I gave Alex a book um
uh which is the topic of the book is
what happens when scientists basically
stray off the path of technical
knowledge and start to weigh in on
politics and societal issues in this
case philosophers philosophers but he
actually talks in this book about like I
talked about the nuclear age and
Einstein he talks about the physicists
uh actually uh doing doing uh very
similar things at the time the book is
when reason goes on holiday philosophers
and politics by uh Nevin and it's just a
story it's a story there's there are
other books on this topic but this is a
new one that's really good it's just a
story of what happens when experts in a
certain domain decide to weigh in and
become basically social engineers and uh
and the political um you know basically
political advisors and it's just a story
of just unending catastrophe
right and I think that's what happened
with covet again
yeah I found this book a highly
entertaining and eye-opening read filled
with the amazing anecdotes of
irrationality and craziness by famous
recent philosophers after you read this
book you will not look at Einstein the
same oh boy yeah don't destroy my heroes
anymore
um I'm sorry you shouldn't read the book
all right but here's the thing the AI
the AI risk people they don't even have
the covet model
at least not that I'm aware of no like
there's not even the equivalent of the
government model they don't even have
the spaghetti code
they've got a theory and a warning and a
this and that and like if you ask like
okay well here's here's the I mean the
ultimate example is okay how do we know
right how do we know that an AI is
running away like how do we know that
the film takeoff thing is actually
happening and the only answer that any
of these guys have given that I've ever
seen is oh it's when the loss rate the
loss uh function and the training drops
right that's when you need to like shut
down the data center right and it's like
well that's also what happens when
you're successfully training a model
like
like what what even is this is not
science this is not it's not anything
it's not a model it's not anything
there's nothing to arguing with it it's
like you know pushing Jello like there's
what do you even respond to uh so did
you put pushback on that I don't think
they have
good metrics of yeah wonderful is
happening but I think it's possible to
have that like I just just as you speak
now I mean it's possible to imagine
there could be measures it's been 20
years no for sure but it's been only
weeks since we had a big enough
breakthrough in language models we can
start to actually have this the thing is
the AI Doomer stuff didn't have any
actual systems to really work with and
now there's real systems you can start
to analyze like how does this stuff go
wrong and I think you kind of agree that
there is a lot of risks that we can
analyze the benefits outweigh the risks
in many cases but the risks are not
existential yes well not not in the food
not in the phone paper clip now so let
me okay there's another sleight of hand
that you just alluded to there's another
sleight of hand that happens which is
very I think I'm very good at the
sleight of hand thing which is very not
scientific so the book super
intelligence right which is like the
Nick bostrom's book which is like the
origin of a lot of this stuff which was
written you know whatever 10 years ago
or something so he does this really
fascinating thing in the book which is
he basically says
um uh there are many possible routes to
machine intelligence to artificial
intelligence and he describes all the
different routes to artificial
intelligence all the different possible
everything from biological augmentation
through to you know done all these
different things
um one of the ones that he does not
describe is large language models
because of course the book was written
before they were invented and so they
didn't exist
in the book he just he describes them
all and then he proceeds to treat them
all as if they're exactly the same thing
he presents them all as sort of an
equivalent risk to be dealt with in an
equivalent way to be thought about the
same way and then the risk the
quote-unquote risk that's actually
emerged is actually a completely
different technology than he was even
imagining and yet all of his theories
and beliefs are being transplanted by
this movement like straight on this new
technology and so again like there's no
other area of science or technology
where you do that yeah like when you're
dealing with like organic chemistry
versus inorganic chemistry you don't
just like say oh with respect to like
either one basically maybe you know
growing up and eating the world or
something like they're just going to
operate the same way like you don't but
you can start talking about like as as
we get more and more actual systems that
start to get more and more intelligent
you can start to actually have more
scientific arguments here like you know
high level you can talk about the threat
of autonomous weapon systems back before
we had any Automation in in the military
and that would be like very fuzzy kind
of logic but the more and more you have
drones that are becoming more and more
autonomous you can start imagining okay
what does that actually look like and
what's the actual threat of autonomous
weapon systems How does it go wrong and
still it's it's very vague but you start
to get a sense of like all right
um it should probably be illegal or
wrong or not allowed to do like
Mass deployment of fully autonomous
drones that are doing aerial strikes oh
no on large areas I think it should be
required right so that's no no I think
if you're required that only
aerial vehicles are automated
okay so you want to go the other way I
want to go the other way so that okay I
think it's obvious that the machine is
going to make a better decision than the
human pilot
I think it's obvious that it's in the
best interest of both the attacker and
the defender and Humanity at large if
machines are making more of these
decisions and not people I think people
make terrible decisions in times of War
but like there's a there's ways this can
go wrong too right well the words go
terribly wrong now
this goes back to the this is that whole
thing about like this Ultra it is the
self-driving car need to be perfect
versus does it need to be better than
the human driver yeah does the automated
drone need to be perfect or does it need
to be better than a human pilot at
making decisions under enormous amounts
of stress and uncertainty yeah well the
on average
the the worry
that AI folks have is the runaway
they're going to come alive right then
again that's the sleight of hand right
or not not come alive well no hold on a
second you're becoming do you lose
control but then they're going to
develop goals of their own they're going
to develop them under their own they're
going to develop their own right no more
more like uh Chernobyl style meltdown
like uh just bugs in the code
accidentally you know Force you the the
results in the bombing of like large
civilian areas okay and to a degree
that's not possible
um in in the current uh military
strategies well actually we've been
doing a lot of mass bombings to cities
for a very long time yes and a lot of
civilians died a lot of civilians died
and if you watch the documentary The Fog
of War McNamara it's been a big part of
it talking about the firebombing of the
Japanese cities yeah bringing them
straight to the ground right the
devastation in Japan American Military
uh firebombing the cities in Japan was
considerably bigger Devastation than the
use of nukes right so we've been doing
that for a long time we also did that
Germany by the way Germany did that to
us right like that's an old tradition
the minute we got airplanes we started
doing indiscriminate bombing so one of
the things we're still doing it the
modern U.S uh military can do with
technology with automation but
technology more broadly is uh higher and
higher Precision strikes yeah well so
Precision is obviously and this is the
the jdam right so there's this big
Advance this big Advance um called the
JDM which basically was strapping a GPS
transceiver to uh to a to an unguided
bomb and turning it into a guided guided
bomb and yeah that's great like look
that's been a big advance but and that's
like a baby version of this question
which is okay do you want like the human
pilot like guessing where the bomb's
gonna land or do you want like the
machine like getting the bottom twist
destination
that's a baby version of the question
the next version of the question is do
you want the human or the machine
deciding whether to drop the bomb
everybody just assumes the human's going
to do a better job for what I think are
fundamentally suspicious reasons
emotional psychological reasons I think
it's very clear that the machine's going
to do a better job making that decision
because the humans making that making
that decision are god-awful just
terrible yeah right and so so yeah so
this is the this is the thing and then
let's get to the there's can I one more
slide of hand okay please I'm a magician
you could say one more sleight of hand
these things are going to be so smart
right that they're going to be able to
destroy the world and wreak havoc and
like do all this stuff and plan and do
all the stuff and evade us and have all
their secret things and their secret
factories and all this stuff but they're
so stupid that they're going to get like
tangled up in their code and that's
they're not going to come alive but
there's going to be some bug that's
going to cause them to like turn us all
into paper like that they're not gonna
they're gonna be genius in every way
other than the actual bad goal
and it's just like and that's just like
a like ridiculous like discrepancy and
and and you can prove this today you can
actually address this today for the
first time with llms which is you can
actually ask llms to resolve uh moral
dilemmas yeah so you can create the
scenario you know dot dot dot this that
this that this that what would you as
the AI do in the circumstance and they
don't just say Destroy All Humans
Destroy All Humans they will give you
actually very nuanced moral practical
trade-off oriented answers so we
actually already have the kind of AI
that can actually like think this
through and can actually like you know
reason about goals well the the hope is
that AGI or like a very super
intelligent systems have some of the
Nuance that llms have and the intuition
is they most likely will because even
these llms have the Nuance uh elements
are really this is actually worth worth
um spending moment on LMS are really
interesting to have moral conversations
with and that
is I didn't expect I'd be having a moral
conversation with a machine in my
lifetime well and let's remember we're
not really having a conversation with a
machine where we're having a
conversation with the entirety of the
collective intelligence of the human
species exactly yeah correct but it's
possible to imagine autonomous weapon
systems that are not using llms but if
they're smart enough to be scary
why are they not smart enough to be wise
like that's the part where it's like I
don't know how you get the one without
the other is it possible to be super
intelligent without being Super Wise
well you're again you're back to that I
mean then you're back to a classic
autistic computer right like you're back
to just like a blind rule follower I've
got this like core is the paperclip
thing I've got this core Rule and I'm
just going to follow it to the end of
the Earth and it's like well but
everything you're going to be doing
execute that rule is going to be super
genius level that humans aren't going to
be able to counter it's just a it's a
it's a mismatch in the definition of
what the system is capable of unlikely
but not impossible I think but again
here you get to like okay like no I'm
not saying when it's unlikely but not
impossible if it's unlikely that means
the the fear should be correctly
calibrated extraordinary claims require
extraordinary proof well okay so uh one
interesting sort of tangent I would love
to take on this because you mentioned
this in the essay about nuclear which
was also
I mean you don't shy away from a little
bit of uh of a spicy take
so uh uh Robert Oppenheimer famously
said no I am become death the destroyer
of worlds as he witnessed the first
detonation of a nuclear weapon on July
16th 1945 and you write an interesting
historical perspective uh quote recall
that John Von Neumann responded to Robin
Robert oppenheimer's famous handwringing
about the role of creating nuclear
weapons which you note helped end World
War II and prevent World War III
with some people confess guilt to claim
credit for the sin and you also
mentioned that Truman was harsher after
meeting Oppenheimer he said that uh
don't let that crybaby be in here again
real quick real quick by the way
promoting it from Dean Atchison
oh boy because Oppenheimer didn't just
say the famous line yeah he then spent
years going around basically moaning him
you know going on TV and going into
going into the White House and basically
like just like doing this hair shirt you
know thing self you know this sort of
self-critical like oh my God I can't
believe how awful I am so he's the the
he's widely considered
perhaps because of the Hang ringing is
the father of the atomic bomb
um this is my name is criticism of him
as he tried to have his cake and eat it
too like he wanted to in in
soyman of course a very different kind
of personality and he's just like yeah
this is like an incredibly useful thing
I'm glad we did it yeah well if I know
him as as widely
um credit is being one of the smartest
humans of the 20th century there's
certain certain people everybody says
like this is the smartest person I've
ever met when they've met him anyway uh
that doesn't mean smart doesn't mean
wise
so the guy I would love to sort of can
you make the case both for and against
the critique of Oppenheimer here because
we're talking about nuclear weapons boy
do they seem dangerous well so the
critique goes deeper and I left this out
here's the real substance I left it out
because I didn't want to dwell on nukes
in my paper
but here's the deeper thing that
happened and I'm really curious this
movie coming out this summer I'm really
curious to see how far he pushes this
because this is the real drama in the
story which is it wasn't just a question
of our nukes good or bad it was a
question of should Russia also have them
um and what what actually happened um
was Russia got the America invented the
bomb Russia got the bomb they got the
bomb through Espionage they got American
and you know they got American
scientists and foreign scientists
working on the American project some
combination of the two uh basically gave
the Russians the designs for the bomb
and that's how the Russians got the bomb
um there's this dispute to this day of
oppenheimer's role in that
um if you read all the histories the
kind of composite picture and by the way
we now know a lot actually about Soviet
Espionage in that era because there's
been all this Declassified material in
the last 20 years that actually shows a
lot of a lot of very interesting things
but if you kind of read all the
histories that you kind of get is
Oppenheimer himself probably was not a
he probably did not hand over the
nuclear secrets himself however he was
close to many people who did yeah
including family members and there were
other members of the Manhattan Project
who were Russian Soviet assets and did
hand over the bomb and so the view of
that Oppenheimer and people like him had
that this thing is awful and terrible
and oh my God and you know all this
stuff you could argue argue fed into
this ethos at the time that resulted in
people thinking that the Baptists
thinking that the only principal thing
to do was to give the Russians the bomb
um and so the the moral beliefs on this
thing and the public discussion and the
role that the inventors of this
technology play this is the point of
this book when they kind of take on this
sort of public intellectual moral kind
of thing it can have real consequences
right because we live in a very
different world today because Russia got
the bomb than we would have lived in had
they not gotten the bomb right the
entire 20th century second half the 20th
century would have played out very
different had those people not given a
rush of the bomb and so the stakes were
very high then the good news today is
nobody's sitting here today I don't
think worrying about like an analogous
situation with respect to like I'm not
really worried that Sam Walton was going
to decide to give you know the Chinese
the design for
yeah although he did just speak at a
Chinese conference which is interesting
but however I don't think I don't think
that's what's at play here but what's at
play here are all these other
fundamental issues around what do we
believe about this and then what laws
and regulations and restrictions that
we're going to put on it and and that's
where I draw like a direct straight line
and anyway and my reading of the history
on nukes is like the people who were
doing the full hair shirt public this is
awful this is terrible actually had like
catastrophically bad results uh from
from taking those views um and that's
what I'm worried it's gonna happen again
but is there a case to be made that you
really need to wake the public up to the
dangers of nuclear weapons when they
were first dropped like really like
educate them on like this is extremely
dangerous and destructive weapon I think
the education kind of happened quick and
early like wow it was pretty obvious wow
we dropped one bomb and destroyed an
entire city
yeah so 80 000 people then what uh hey
look but I don't like the reporting of
that you can report that in all kinds of
ways of course you can you can do all
kinds of Slants like war is horrible war
is terrible you can do you can make it
seem like nuclear the use of nuclear
weapons is just a part of war and all
that kind of stuff something about the
reporting in the discussion of nuclear
weapons resulted in us being
terrified in awe of the power of nuclear
weapons and that potentially
fed in a positive way towards the the
game theory of mutually shared
destruction well so this gets to what
actually happened let's get to what some
of us Playing devil's advocate here yeah
yeah sure of course let's get to what
actually happened and then kind of back
into that so what actually happened I
believe and again I think this is a
reasonable reading of history is what
actually happened was nukes then
prevented World War III and they
prevented World War III through the game
theory of mutually assured destruction
had nukes not existed right there would
have been no reason why the cold war did
not go hot right and then they're and
then you know in the military planners
at the time right thought both on both
sides thought that there was going to be
World War III on the planes of Europe
and they thought there was going to be
like 100 million people dead right it
was like the most obvious thing in the
world to happen
right and it's the dog that didn't bark
right like it may be like the best
single net thing that happened in the
entire 20th century is it like that
didn't happen yeah actually just at that
point you say a lot of really brilliant
things it hit me just as you were saying
it
I don't know why it hit me for the first
time but we got two Wars in a span of
like uh 20 years
like we could have kept getting more and
more world wars more and more ruthless
it actually you could have had a US
versus Russia War you could have
by the way you have there's another
hypothetical scenario the other
hypothetical scenario is the Americans
got the bomb the Russians didn't
right and then America's the big dog and
then maybe America would have had the
capability to actually roll back the
Iron Curtain
right now I don't know whether that
would have happened but like it's
entirely possible right and and and the
act of these people who have these moral
positions about because they could
forecast they could model they could
forecast the future of how this
technology would get used made a
horrific mistake because they basically
ensured that the Aaron Curtin would
continue for 50 years longer than it
would have otherwise and again like
these are counterfactuals I don't know
that that's what would have happened but
like
[Music]
the decision to hand the bomb over was a
big decision
made by people who were very full of
themselves
yeah but so me as an America me as a
person that loves America I also wonder
if us was the only ones with the nuclear
weapons
uh that was the argument for Handy that
was the was uh the guys who the guys who
handed over the bomb that was actually
their moral argument yeah I would I
would probably not hand it over to I
would be careful about the regimes you
handed over to maybe you give it to like
the British or something
or like uh like a democratically elected
government well look there are people to
this day who think that those Soviet
spies did the right thing because they
created a balance of Terror as opposed
to the us having just and by the way let
me let me balance of Terror let's tell
the full version that's such a sexy ring
to it okay so the full version of the
story is John Von Neiman's a hero of
both Heroes and mine the full version of
the story is he advocated for a first
strike so when the U.S had the bomb and
Russia did not he advocated for he said
we need to strike them right now
strike Russia yeah
yes
because he said World War III is
inevitable
um he was very hardcore uh he his his
theory was
um his theory was World War III is
inevitable we're definitely going to
have world war three the only way to
stop world war three is we have to take
them out right now and we have to take
them out right now before they get the
bomb because this is our last chance
now again like is this an example of
philosophers in politics I don't know if
that's in there or not but this is in
the standard box no but it is it meaning
yeah this is on the other side so so
most of the case studies most of the
case studies in books like this are the
crazy people on the left yeah
um Von Neumann is a story arguably of
the crazy people on the right
um yeah stick to Computing John well
this is the thing and this is this is
the general principle is it going to
affect our core thing which is like I
don't know whether any of these people
should be making any of these calls yeah
because there's nothing in either Von
Neumann's background or oppenheimer's
background or any of these people's
background that qualifies them as moral
authorities yeah well this actually
brings up the point of Nai who are the
good people to to reason about the
morality the ethics the outside of these
risks outside like the more complicated
stuff that you you agree on is you know
this will go into the hands of bad guys
and all the kinds of ways they'll do is
is interesting and dangerous
um is dangerous and interesting
unpredictable ways and who is the right
person who are the right kinds of people
to make decisions how respond to it is
attack people so the history of these
fields this is what he talks about in
the book The History of these fields is
that the the competence and capability
and intelligence and training and
accomplishments of senior scientists and
technologists working on a technology
and then being able to then make moral
judgments in the use of the technology
that track record is terrible
that tracker that track record is like
catastrophically bad
um and the people just illuminate the
people that developed that technology
are usually not going to be the right
people
well why would they so the claim is of
course they're the knowledgeable ones
but the problem is they've spent their
entire life in a lab right they're not
theologians but so what you find what
you find when you read when you read
this when you look at these histories
which you find is they generally are
very thinly informed on history on
sociology on on on theology on morality
ethics they tend to manufacture their
own world views from scratch they tend
to be very sort of thin
um
they're not remotely the arguments that
you would be having if you got like a
group of Highly qualified theologians or
philosophers or you know um well let me
uh sort of uh as The Devil's Advocate
takes a sip of whiskey say that
I I agree with uh
with that but also it seems like the
people who are doing kind of the ethics
departments and these tax tech companies
go sometimes the other way yes
they're not nuanced on the on history or
theology or this kind of stuff they it
almost becomes a kind of outraged
activism towards
um
directions that don't seem to be
grounded in history and humility and
Nuance it's again drenched with
arrogance so so definitely I'm not sure
which is worse oh no they're both bad
yeah so definitely not them either so
but I guess what this is a hard yeah
it's a hard problem that's not a problem
and this goes back to where we started
which is okay who has the truth and it's
like well
um you know like how do Society survive
at like truth and how do we figure these
things out and like our elected leaders
play some role in it
you know we all play some role in it
um there have to be some set of public
intellectuals at some point that bring
you know rationality and judgment
humility to it yeah those people are few
and far between we should probably prize
them very highly yes celebrate humility
in our public leaders uh so getting to
risk number two will AI ruin our society
short version as you write if the murder
robots don't get us the hate speech and
misinformation will
and the action you recommend in short
don't let the thought police suppress AI
well what is uh
this risk of the effect of
misinformation of society that's going
to be catalyzed by AI yeah so this is
the social media this is what you just
alluded to it's the activism kind of
thing that's popped up in these
companies and in the industry and it's
basically from my perspective it's
basically part two of the war that
played out over social media over the
last 10 years
um because you probably remember social
media 10 years ago was basically who
even wants this who wants who wants a
photo of what your cat had for breakfast
like this stuff is like silly interview
and why can't these nerds like figure
out how to invent something like useful
and powerful and then you know certain
things happened in the political system
and then it's sort of the polarity on
that discussion switched all the way to
social media is like the worst most
corrosive most terrible most awful
technology ever invented and it leads to
you know terrible the wrong you know
politicians and policies and politics
and like and all this stuff and and that
that all got catalyzed into this very
big kind of angry movement both inside
and outside the companies to kind of
bring social media to to heal and that
got focused in particularly on two
topics so-called hate speech and
so-called misinformation
um and that's been to Saga playing out
for the last for the last decade and I
don't even really want to even argue the
pros and cons of the sides just to
observe that that's been like a huge
fight and it's had you know big
consequences to how these companies
operate
um basically that same those same sets
of theories that same activist approach
that same energy as being transplanted
straight to Ai and you see that already
happening it's why you know GPT will
answer let's say certain questions and
not others
um it's why it gives you the canned
speech about you know whenever it starts
with as a large language model I cannot
you know basically means that somebody
has reached in there and told it it
can't talk about certain topics
um do you think some of that is good so
it's a it's an interesting question
um so a couple of couple observations um
so so one is um the people who find this
the most frustrating are the people who
are worried about the murder robots
people right they started with the term
AI safety the term became AI alignment
when the term became AI alignment is
when this switch happened from or where
it is going to kill us all we're worried
about hate speech and misinformation
sure the AIX risk people have now
renamed their thing uh AI not kill
everyone ISM
um which I have to admit is a catchy
term and they are very frustrated by the
fact that the sort of activist driven
hate speech misinformation kind of thing
is taking over which is what's happened
it's taken over the AI ethics field has
been taken over by the hate speech
misinformation people
um you know look would I like to live in
a world in which like everybody was nice
to each other all the time and nobody
ever said anything mean and nobody ever
used a bad word and everything was
always accurate and honest like that
sounds great do I want to live in a
world where there's like a centralized
thought police working through the tech
companies to enforce the view of a small
set of Elites that they're going to
determine what the rest of us think and
feel like absolutely not they could be a
middle ground somewhere like Wikipedia
type of moderation there's moderation of
Wikipedia
that is somehow crowdsourced where you
don't have centralized Elites
uh but it's also not completely just a
free-for-all because uh the if you have
the entirety of human knowledge at your
fingertips you can do a lot of harm like
if you have a good assistant that's
completely uncensored it can help you
build a bomb they can help you
um mess
with people's physical well-being right
if they because that information is out
there on the internet and so they're
presumably there's it would be
you could see the positives in um
censoring some aspects of an AI model
when it's helping you commit literal
violence yeah and there's a section
later section of the essay where I talk
about bad people doing bad things yes
right which which and and there's a
there's a set of things that we should
discuss there yeah um what happens in
practice is these line as you alluded to
this already these lines are not easy to
draw and what I've observed in the
social media version of this is the way
I describe it as the slippery slope is
not a fallacy it's an inevitability the
minute you have this kind of activist
personality that gets in a position to
make these decisions they they take it
straight to Infinity like they they it
it goes into the crazy Zone like almost
immediately and never comes back because
people become drunk with power um right
and they look if you're in the position
to determine what the entire world
thinks and feels and reads and says like
you're going to take it
and you know Elon has you know
ventilated this with the Twitter files
over the last you know three months and
it's just like Crystal Clear like how
bad it got there now yeah reason for
optimism is what uh Elon is doing with
the community notes
um
um so Community knows is actually a very
interesting thing uh so what Elon is
trying to do with Community notes um is
he's trying to have it where there's
only a community note when people who
have previously disagreed on many topics
agree on this one
yes that's interesting that's what
that's what I'm trying to get at is like
there's there could be Wikipedia like
models a community knows type of models
where allows you to essentially either
provide context or censor in a way
that's not resist the slippery slope
nature now there's another Power there's
an entirely different approach here
which is basically
um we have AIS that are producing
content we can also have AIS that are
consuming content yeah right and so one
of the things that your assistant could
do for you is help you consume all the
content right and basically tell you
when you're getting played so for
example I'm going to want the AI that my
kid uses right to be very you know child
safe and I'm going to want it to filter
for him all kinds of inappropriate stuff
that he shouldn't be saying just because
he's a kid yeah right and you see what
I'm saying is you can Implement that you
could use the architectural you could
say you can solve this on the client
side right solving on the server side
gives you an opportunity to dictate for
the entire world which I think is where
you you take the slippery slope to Hell
there's another architectural approach
which is to solve this on the client
side which is certainly what I would
endorse
it's uh at risk number five will AI lead
uh to bad people doing bad things and I
can just imagine language models used to
do so many bad things but the hope is
there that you can have
uh large language models used to then
defend against it by more people by
smarter people by more effective people
skilled people all that kind of stuff
three-point argument on bad people doing
bad things um so um uh so number one
right you can use the technology
defensively and there's a we should be
using AI to build like broad spectrum
vaccines and antibiotics for like
bioweapons and we should be using it to
like hunt terrorists and catch criminals
and like we should be doing like all
kinds of stuff like that in fact we
should be doing those things even just
to like go get like you know basically
go eliminate risk from like regular
pathogens that aren't like constructed
by an AI so there's there's the whole um
uh there's a whole defensive set of
things um second is we have many laws on
the books about the actual bad things
right so it is actually illegal to be a
you know to commit crimes to to commit
terrorist acts to you know build
pathogens with the intent to deploy them
to kill people and so we have those we
don't we actually don't need new laws
for the vast majority of the scenarios
we actually already have the laws in the
book
on the books the third argument is the
minute and this is sort of the
foundational one that gets really tough
but the minute you get into this thing
which which you were kind of getting
into which is like okay but like don't
you need censorship sometimes right and
don't you need restrictions sometimes
it's like okay what is the cost of that
um and in particular in the world of
Open Source right
um and so um is open source AI going to
be allowed or not
um if open source AI is not allowed
um then what is the regime that's going
to be necessary legally and technically
to prevent it from developing
right and here again is where you get
into and people have proposed these
kinds of things you get into I would say
pretty extreme territory pretty fast do
we have a monitor agent on every CPU and
GPU that reports back to the government
what we're doing with our computers are
we seizing GPU clusters that get Beyond
a certain size like and then by the way
how are we doing all that globally right
and like if China is developing an llm
beyond the scale that we think is
allowable are we going to invade right
and you have figures on the AIX risk
side who are advocating and you know
potentially up to nuclear strikes to
prevent you know this kind of thing and
so here you get into this thing and
again you know you could maybe say this
is you know you could even say this is
what good bad or indifferent or whatever
but like here's the the comparison of
the nukes the comparison of nukes is
very dangerous because one is just nukes
for just just about although we can come
back to nuclear power but the other
thing was like with nukes you could
control plutonium right you could track
plutonium and it was like hard to come
by
AI is just math and code right it's and
it's in like math textbooks and it's
like their YouTube videos that teach you
how to build it and like there's open
source there's already open source you
know there's a 40 billion parameter
model running around already called
Falcon Online that anybody can download
um and so okay you walk down the logic
path that says we need to have
guardrails on this and you find yourself
in a authoritarian totalitarian regime
of thought control and machine control
that would be so brutal that you would
have destroyed the society that you're
trying to protect and so I I just don't
see how that actually works so yeah you
have to understand my brain has gone a
full uh full steam ahead here because I
agree with uh basically everything
you're saying when I'm trying to play
devil's advocate here there because okay
you've highlighted the fact that there
is a slippery slope to human nature the
moment you censor something
you start to censor everything
um
the alignment starts out sounding nice
but then you start align to uh the
beliefs of some
select group of people and then it's
just your beliefs the the number the
number of people you're lying to is
smaller and smaller as that group
becomes more and more powerful okay but
that just speaks to the people that
censor are usually the assholes and the
assholes get richer I wonder if it's
possible to do without that for AI the
one way to ask this question
is do you think the base models the the
base the Baseline Foundation model
should be open sourced
like uh what where Mark Zuckerberg is
saying they want to do so I look I mean
I think it's totally appropriate that
companies that are in the business of
producing a product or service should be
able to have a wide range of policies
that they put right and now just again I
want a heavily censored model for my
eight-year-old like I actually want that
like like I would pay more money for the
ones more heavily censored than the one
that's not right
um and so like there are certainly
scenarios where companies will make that
decision look an interesting thing you
brought up the or is is this really a
speech issue um one of the things that
the big tech companies are dealing with
is that content generated uh from an llm
is not covered under Section 230 uh
which is the law that uh protects
internet platform companies from being
sued for the user generated content
um and so it it's actually yes and so
there's actually a there's actually a
question I think there's still a
question which is can big can big
American companies actually feel
generative AI at all or is the liability
actually gonna just ultimately convince
them that they can't do it because the
minute the thing says some something bad
and it doesn't even need to be hate
speech it could just be like an enact it
could hallucinate a product you know
detail on a vacuum cleaner you know and
all of a sudden the vacuum cleaner
company sues for misrepresentation and
there's any symmetry there right because
the the LM is going to be producing
billions of answers to questions and it
only needs to get a few wrongs the loss
has to get updated really quick here
yeah and nobody knows what to do with
that right um so anyway like they're
they're a big they're big questions
around how companies operate at all so
we talk about those but then there's
this other question of like okay the
open source so what about open source
and my answer to your question is kind
of like obviously yes the models have
there has to be full open source here
because to live in a world in which that
open source is not allowed is a world of
draconian speech control human control
machine control I mean you know black
helicopters with Jack booted thugs
coming out repelling down and seizing
your GPU like territory well no no I'm
100 serious that's you're saying
slippery slope always leads there no no
no no no that's what's required to
enforce it like how will you enforce a
ban on open
you could add friction to it like harder
to get the models because people will
always be able to get the models but
it'll be more in the shadows right the
leading opens first model right now is
from the UAE it's like the next time
they do that
what do we do yeah like oh I see you're
like uh the 14 year old in Indonesia
comes out with a breakthrough model you
know we talked about most great software
comes from a small number of people some
kid comes out with some big new
breakthrough in quantization or
something and he has some huge
breakthrough and like what we're gonna
what are we gonna like
invade Indonesia and arrest him it seems
like in terms of size and models and
effectiveness of models the big tech
companies will probably lead the way for
quite a few years and and the question
is of what policies they should use the
the kid the kid in Indonesia should not
be regulated but should Google meta
uh Microsoft open AI be regulated well
so but this goes okay so when does it
become dangerous yeah
right is is the danger that it's quote
as powerful as the current leading
commercial model or is it that it is it
is just at some other arbitrary
threshold yeah and then by the way like
look how do we know like what we know
today is that you need like a lot of
money to like train these things but
their advances being made every week on
training efficiency and you know data
all kinds of synthetic you know look I
don't even like the synthetic data thing
we're talking about maybe some kid
figures out a way to Auto generate
synthetically it's going to change
everything yeah exactly and so like
sitting here today like the the
Breakthrough just happened right you
made this point like the Breakthrough
just happened so we don't know what the
shape of this technology is going to be
I mean the the big shock the the big
shock here is that you know whatever
number of billions of parameters
basically represents at least a very big
percentage of human thought like who
would have imagined that
and then there's already work underway
there was just this paper that just came
out that basically takes the gpt3 scale
model and compresses it down to run on a
single 32 core CPU
like who would have predicted that yeah
um you know some of these models now you
can run a Raspberry Pi's like today
they're very slow but like you know
maybe they'll be a you know perform you
know like
it's math and here we're back in here
we're back math and code it's math and
codes math code and data it's bits marks
just like blocked away at this point
he's just screw it I don't know what to
do with this you guys created this whole
internet thing yeah yeah I mean I'm a
huge believer in open source here so my
argument is we're gonna have to see
here's my argument my argument my full
argument is AI is going to be like air
it's going to be everywhere like this is
just going to be in Texas it already is
it's going to be in textbooks and kids
are going to grow up knowing how to do
this and it's just going to be a thing
it's going to be in the air and you
can't like pull this back anywhere you
can pull back air and so you just have
to figure out how to live in this world
right and then that and then that's
where I think like all this hand ringing
but air risk is basically complete waste
of time because the the the effort
should go into okay what are what what
is the defensive approach and so if
you're worried about you know AI
generated pathogens the right thing to
do is to have a permanent project warp
speed right funded lavishly let's do it
Manhattan let's talk about let's do a
Manhattan project for biological defense
right and let's build AIS and let's have
like broad spectrum vaccines where like
we're insulated from every pathogen
well the interesting thing is because
it's software
a kid in his basement teenager could
build like a system that defends against
like the worst the the worst I mean and
to me defense is super exciting
it's to like I If you believe in the
good of human nature that most people
want to do good to be the savior of
humanity is really exciting
yes
okay that's a dramatic statement but
like to help people to help people
yeah okay what about just the jump
around what about the risk of will AI
lead to crippling inequality
you know because we're kind of saying
everybody's life will become better
is it possible that the the rich get
richer here yeah so this is actually
ironically goes back to Marxism so um
because this was the code so the court
claim of Marxism right basically was
that the owner the owners of capital
would basically own the means of
production and then over time they would
basically accumulate all the wealth the
workers would be paying in you know and
getting nothing in return because they
wouldn't be needed anymore right marks
was very worried about what he called
mechanization or what later became known
as automation
um and that you know the workers would
be miserated and the capitalists would
end up with with all and so this was one
of the core core core principles of
Marxism of course it turned out to be
wrong about every previous wave of
Technology
um the reason it turned out to be wrong
about every previous wave of technology
is that the way that the self-interested
owner of the machines makes the most
money is by providing the production
capability in the form of products and
services to the most people the most
customers as possible Right the largest
this is one of those funny things where
every CEO knows this intuitively and yet
it's like hard to explain from the
outside the the way you make the most
money in any business is by selling to
the largest market you can possibly get
to the largest market you can possibly
get to is everybody the planet and so
every large company does is everything
that it can to drive down prices to be
able to get volumes up to be able to get
to everybody on the planet and that
happened with everything from
electricity it happened with telephones
it happened with radio it happened with
automobiles it happened with smartphones
it happened with the PCS it happened
with the internet it happened with
mobile broadband it's happened by the
way with Coca-Cola and it's happened
with like every you know basically every
industrially produced you know good or
service people you want to drive it to
the largest possible market and then as
proof of that it's already happened
right which is the early adopters of
like jgpt and Bing are not like you know
Exxon and Boeing they're you know your
uncle and your nephew right it's just
like free it's either freely available
online or it's available for 20 bucks a
month or something but it you know these
things went this this technology went
Mass Market immediately
um and so look the the owners of the
means of production whoever does this
doesn't mention these trillion other
questions there are people who are going
to get really rich doing this producing
these things but they're going to get
really rich by taking this technology to
the broadest possible Market
so yes they'll get rich but they'll get
rich having a huge positive impact on
yeah making that making the technology
available to everybody yeah right and
again smartphone same thing right so
there's this amazing kind of twist in um
in business history which is you cannot
spend ten thousand dollars on a
smartphone
right you can't spend a hundred thousand
dollars you can't spend like I would buy
the million dollar smartphone like I'm
signed up for it like if it's like
suppose a million dollar smartphone was
like much better than the thousand
dollar smartphone like I'm there to buy
it it doesn't exist why doesn't it exist
Apple makes so much more money driving
the price further down from a thousand
dollars than they would trying to
harvest right and so it's just this
repeating pattern you see over and over
again um where the and and what's what's
great about it what's great about it is
you do not need to rely on anybody's
enlightened right generosity to do this
you just need to rely on capitalist
self-interest
uh what about AI taking our jobs
yeah so very very similar thing here um
there's sort of a there's a core fallacy
which again was was very common in
Marxism which is What's called the lump
of Labor fallacy and this is sort of the
fallacy that there's a only a fixed
amount of work to be done in the world
and if the and it's all being done today
by people and then if machines do it
there's no other work to be done by
people
um and that's just a completely
backwards view on how the economy
develops and grows um because what
happens is not in fact that what happens
is the introduction of Technology into
production process causes prices to fall
as prices fall consumers have more
spending power is consumers have more
spending power they create new demand
that new demand then causes capital and
labor to form into new Enterprises to
satisfy nuance and needs and the result
is more jobs and higher wages the nuance
and needs the the worries that the the
creation of new wants and needs at a
rapid rate
will mean there's a lot of turnover in
jobs so people will lose jobs just the
actual experience of losing a job and
having to learn new things and your
skills is painful for the individual
well two things one is the new jobs are
often much better
um so this actually came up as if there
was this Panic about a decade ago and
all the truck drivers are going to lose
their jobs right and number one that
didn't happen because we haven't figured
out a way to actually finish that yet
but but the other thing was like
electric driver like I grew up in a town
that was basically consisted of a truck
stop right and I like knew a lot of
truck drivers and like truck drivers
live a decade shorter than everybody
else like they it's a it's a it's
actually like a very dangerous like they
get like literally they have like high
rates of skin cancer and on the left
side of their on the left side of their
body from from being in the sun all the
time the vibration of being in the truck
is actually very damaging to your to
your physiology and there's actually a
uh perhaps partially because of that
reason uh there's a shortage yeah of uh
people who want to be truck drivers yeah
like it's not it's not like the question
always you want to ask somebody like
that is do you want you know do you want
your kid to be doing this job and like
most of them will tell you no like I
want my kid to be sick in a cubicle
somewhere like where they don't have
this like where they don't die 10 years
earlier and so so the new jobs number
one the new jobs are often better but
you don't get the new jobs until you go
through the change and then to your
point the the training thing you know
it's always the issue is can can people
adapt and again here you need to imagine
living in a world in which everybody has
the AI assistant capability
right to be able to pick up new skills
much more quickly and be able to have
some you know be able to have a machine
to work with to augment their skills
it's still going to be painful but
that's the process of life it's painful
for some people I mean there's no look
there's no question it's painful for
some people and they're you know they're
yes it's not again I'm not a utopian on
this and it's not like it's positive for
everybody in the moment but it has been
overwhelmingly positive for 300 years
I mean look the concern here the concern
the concern this concern has played out
for for literally centuries um and you
know this is the sort of what I you know
the story of the ludd eyes
um that you may remember there was a
panic in the 2000s around uh Outsourcing
who's going to take all the jobs there
was a panic in the 2010s that robots are
going to take all the jobs
um
in 2019 before covid we had more jobs at
higher wages both in the country and in
the world than at any point human
history and so the overwhelming evidence
is that the net gain here is like just
like wildly positive and most most
people like overwhelmingly come out the
other side being huge beneficiaries of
this so you write that the single
greatest risk this is the risk you're
most convinced by the single greatest
risk of AI is that China wins Global AI
dominance and we the United States and
the West do not can you elaborate yeah
so this is the other thing which is a
lot of the sort of AI risk debates today
sort of assume that we're the only game
in town right and so we have the ability
to kind of sit in the United States and
criticize ourselves and you know have
our government like you know beat up on
our companies and figure out a way to
restrict what our companies can do and
you know we're gonna you know we're
gonna ban this and ban that restrict
this and do that and then there's this
like other like force out there that
like doesn't believe we have any power
over them whatsoever and they have no
desire to sign up for whatever rules we
decide to put in place
um and they're going to do whatever it
is they're going to do and we have no
control over it at all
and it's China and specifically the
Chinese Communist Party
um and they have a completely publicized
open you know uh plan for what they're
going to do with AI and it is not what
we have in mind
um and not only do they have that as a
vision and a plan for their society but
they also have it as a vision and plan
for the rest of the world so their plan
is what surveillance yeah authoritarian
control so authoritarian population
control
um you know good old-fashioned communist
authoritarian control
um and surveillance and enforcement
um and social credit scores and all the
rest of it
um and you are going to be monitored and
metered within an inch of everything all
the time
um and it's you know basically the end
of human freedom and that's their goal
and you know they justify it on the
basis of that's what leads to peace and
you're worried that the uh
regulating in the United States will
will call progress enough to where uh
the Chinese government would win that
race so their plan yeah yes yes and the
reason for that is they and again
they're very public on this they have
their plan is to prolifer their their
approach around the world and they have
this program called the digital Silk
Road right which is building on their
their Silk Road investment program and
they've got their they've been laying
they've been laying networking
infrastructure all over the world with
their 5G right work with their company
Huawei and so they've been laying all
this fabric but financial and
technological fabric all over the world
and their plan is to roll out their
vision of AI on top of that and to have
every other country be running their
version and then if you're a country
prone to you know authoritarianism
you're going to find this to be an
incredible way to become more
authoritarian uh if you're a country by
the way not prone authoritarianism
you're going to have the Chinese
Communist Party running your
infrastructure and having back doors
into it right which is also not good
um what's your sense of where they stand
in terms of the race towards super
intelligence as compared to the United
States yeah so good news is they're
behind but bad news is they you know
they let's just say they get access to
everything we do
um so they're probably a year behind at
each point in time but they get you know
downloads I think of basically all of
our work on a regular basis through a
variety of means
um and they are you know we'll see
they're at least putting out reports of
very just put out a report last week of
a gpg 3.5 analog
um they put out this report forget what
it's called but um they put out this
report of the cell and they did and they
you know the way when openai you know
puts out they they one of the ways they
test you know a GPT um is they they run
it through standardized exams like the
sat right just how you can kind of cage
how smart it is uh and so the Chinese
report they ran their LM through uh the
Chinese equivalent of the SAT
um and it includes a section on Marxism
um and a section on Mouse thought and it
turns out their AI does very well on
both of those topics
right so like uh this this alignment
thing communist AI right like literal
communist AI right and so their vision
is like that's the you know so you know
you can just imagine like you're a
school you know you're a kid 10 years
from now in Argentina or in Germany or
in who knows where uh Indonesia and you
ask they I'd explain to you like how the
economy works and it gives you're the
most cheery upbeat explanation of
Chinese style communism you've ever
heard right so
like the stakes here are like really big
well my as we've been talking about my
hope is not just with the United States
but it would just uh the kit in his
basement with open source llm because I
I don't know if I
um trust large centralized institutions
with super powerful Ai No matter what
their ideology
is a power corrupts
you've been investing in tech companies
for about let's say 20 years and uh
about 15 of which was uh with Andreessen
Horowitz
uh what interesting Trends in Tech have
you seen over that time let's just talk
about companies and just the evolution
of the tech industry I mean the big
shift over 20 years has been that Tech
used to be a tools industry for
basically from like 1940 through to
about 2010 almost all the big successful
companies were picks and travels
companies so PC database smartphone you
know some some some tool that somebody
else would pick up and use
since 2010 most of the big wins have
been in applications
um so a company that starts a com uh you
know it starts in an existing industry
and goes directly to the customer in
that industry and you know the early
examples there were like uber and Lyft
and Airbnb
um and then that model is kind of
elaborating out
um the AI thing is actually a reversion
on that for now because like most of the
AI business right now is actually in
Cloud provision of of AI apis for other
people to build on but but the big thing
will probably be an app yeah I think I
think most of the money I think probably
will be in whatever yeah your AI
financial advisor or your AI doctor or
your AI lawyer or you know take your
pick of whatever the domain is
um and there and what's interesting is
you know we the valley kind of does
everything we should our entrepreneurs
kind of elaborate every possible idea
and so there will be a set of companies
that like make AI something that can be
purchased and used by large law firms um
and then there will be other companies
that just go direct to Market as a as an
AI lawyer
what advice could you give for a startup
founder just haven't seen so many
successful companies so many companies
that fail also what advice could you
give to a startup founder someone who
wants to build the next super successful
startup in the tech space the Googles
the apples the twitters
yeah so the great thing about the really
great Founders is they don't take any
advice so
so if you find yourself listening to
advice maybe you shouldn't do it
um but that's actually just to elaborate
on that if you could also speak to Great
Founders yeah like what makes a great
founder so what makes a great founder is
super smart
um coupled with super energetic coupled
with super courageous I think it's some
of those those three and intelligence
passion and courage the first two are
traits and the third one is a choice I
think encourage is a choice well because
courage is a question of pain tolerance
right
um
so um how how many times you're willing
to get punched in the face before you
quit yeah um and
here's maybe the biggest thing people
don't understand about what it's like to
be a startup founder is it gets very
romanticized right um and even when it
even when they fail it still gets
romanticized about like what a great
adventure it was but like
the reality of it is most of what
happens is people telling you no and
then they usually follow that with
you're stupid right no I will not come
to work for you um I will not leave my
cushy job at Google can work for you no
I'm not going to buy your products you
know no I'm not going to run a story
about your company no I'm not this that
the other thing
um and so a huge amount of what people
have to do is just get used to just
getting punched and and the reason
people don't understand this is because
when you're a Founder you cannot let on
that this is happening because it will
cause people to think that you're weak
and they'll lose faith in you yeah so
you have to pretend that you're having a
great time when you're dying inside
right
it's just a misery but why why do they
do it what do they do oh yeah that's the
thing it's it's like it is a level it's
actually one of the conclusions I think
is it I think it's actually for most of
these people on a risk adjusted basis
it's probably an irrational act they
could probably be more financially
successful on average if they just got
like a real job in a big company
um but there's you know some people just
have an irrational need to do something
new and build something for themselves
and you know some people just can't
tolerate having bosses oh here's the fun
thing is how do you reference check
founders right so you call it you know
normally you reference check your time
hiring somebody as you call the bosses
if they're in you know and you find out
if they were good employees and now
you're trying to reference check Steve
Jobs right and it's like oh God he was
terrible you know he was a terrible
employee he never did what we told him
to do yeah
so what's a good reference do you want
the previous boss to actually stay there
they never did what you told them to do
that might be a good thing well ideally
ideally what you want is I will go I
would like to go to work for that person
um he worked for me here and now I'd
like to work for him no unfortunately
most people can't their egos can't can't
handle that so they won't say that but
that that's the ideal what advice would
you give to those folks in the space of
intelligence passion and courage so I
think the other big thing is you see
people sometimes who say I want to start
a company and then they kind of work
through the process of coming up with an
idea and generally those don't work as
well as the case where somebody has the
idea first and then they kind of realize
that there's an opportunity to build a
company and then they just turn out to
be the right kind of person to do that
when you say idea do you mean yeah
what long-term big Vision or do you mean
specifics of like product specific let's
say specific like specifically what yes
specifics like what is because for the
first five years you don't get to have
Vision you just got to build something
people want and you've got to figure out
a way to sell it to them right it's very
practical or you never get to Big Vision
so so the first the first part you have
an idea of a set of products or the
first product that can actually make
some money yeah like it's got a first
product's got to work by which I mean
like it has to technically work but then
it has to actually fit into the category
in the customer's mind of something that
they want and then and then by the way
the other part is they have to want to
pay for it like somebody's got to pay
the bills and so you've got to figure
out how to price it and whether you can
actually extract the money yeah so
usually it is much more predictable
success is never predictable but it's
more predictable if you start with a
great idea and then back into starting
the company
um so this is what we did you know
before we escape the Google guys had the
Google search engine working at Stanford
um right um the um uh you know yeah
actually there's tons of examples where
they you know uh Pierre omadir had eBay
working before he left his previous job
so I really love that idea of just
having a thing a prototype that actually
works before you even begin to remotely
scale yeah by the way it's also far
easier to raise money right like the
ideal pitch that we receive is here's
the thing that works would you like to
invest in our company or not like that's
so much easier than here's 30 slides
with a dream right
um and then we have this concept called
the dmas which are apology Serena Boston
came up with um when he was with us um
so so so then there's this thing this
goes to mythology which is um you know
there's a mythology of that kind of you
know these these ideas
um you know kind of arrive like magic or
people kind of stumble into them it's
like eBay with the pest dispensers or
something
um the reality usually with the big
successes is that the founder has been
chewing on the problem for five or ten
years before they start the company and
they often worked on it in school
um or they even experimented on it when
they were a kid
um and they've been kind of training up
over that period of time to be able to
do the thing so they're like a true
domain expert
and and it's it sort of sounds like Mom
and apple pie which is yeah you want to
be a domain expert what you're doing but
you would you know the mythology is so
strong of like oh I just like had this
idea in the shower and now I'm doing it
like it's generally not that no because
well maybe in the shower we had the
exact
product implementation details but yeah
usually you're going to be for like
years if not decades thinking about
like
everything around that well we call it
the idea Mas because the idma is
basically is like there's all these
permutations like for any ID for any
idea there's like all these different
permutations who should the customer be
what shape forms the product have and
how should we take it to Market and all
these things
um and so um the really smart Founders
have thought through all these scenarios
by the time they go out to raise money
um and they have like detailed answers
on every one of those fronts because
they put so much thought into it
um the sort of the the sort of more
haphazard Founders haven't thought about
any of that and it's the detailed ones
who tend to do much better so how do you
know when to take a leap if you have a
cushy job or a happy life
I mean the best reason is just because
you can't tolerate not doing it right
like this is the kind of thing where if
you have to be advised into doing it you
probably shouldn't do it
um and so it's probably the opposite
which is you just have such a burning
sense of this has to be done I have to
do this I have no choice what if it's
going to lead to a lot of pain it's
going to lead to a lot of pain
I think that's what if it means uh
losing sort of social relationships and
damaging your
um relationship with loved ones and all
that kind of stuff yeah look so like
it's going to put you in a social tunnel
for sure right so you're gonna like uh
you know there's this game you can play
on Twitter which is you can do any whiff
of the idea that there's uh basically
any such thing as work-life balance and
that people should actually work hard
and everybody gets mad but like the
truth is like all the successful
Founders are working 80 hour weeks and
they're working you know they perform
very very strong social bonds with the
people they work with they tend to lose
a lot of friends on the outside or put
those friendships on ice like that's
just the nature of the of the thing
um you know for most people it's worth
the trade-off you know the advantage you
know maybe younger Founders have is
maybe they have less you know maybe
they're not you know for example if
they're not married yet or don't have
kids yet that's an easier thing to bite
off
can you be an older founder yeah you
definitely can yeah um yeah many of the
most successful Founders are second
third fourth time Founders they're in
their 30s 40s 50s um the good news of
being an older founder is you know more
and you you know a lot more about what
to do which is very helpful the problem
is okay now you've got like a spouse and
a family and kids and like you've got to
go to the baseball game and like you
can't go to the base you know and so
it's it
life is full of difficult choices yes
uh you've written a blog post on what
you've been up to uh you wrote this in
October 2022 I quote mostly I try to
learn a lot
for example the political events of 2014
to 2016 made clear to me that I didn't
understand politics at all referencing
maybe some of this this book here
um so I deliberately withdrew from
political engagement and fundraising and
instead read my way back into history
and as far to the political left and
political right as I could so just high
level question what's your approach to
learning
yeah so it's basically I would say it's
it's an Auto Direct
um uh so it's sort of goes it's going
down the rabbit holes so it's a
combination let's say I kind of allude
to it in that quote It's a combination
of breadth and depth
um and so I tend to yeah I tend to I go
abroad by the nature of what I do I go
broad but then I tend to go deep in a
rabbit hole for a while read everything
I can and then come out of it and I
might I might not revisit that rabbit
hole for you know another decade and in
that blog post that I'd recommend people
go check out you actually list a bunch
of different books that you recommend on
different topics on the American left
and the American right
uh it's just a lot of really good stuff
the best explanation for the current
structure of our society in politics you
give to recommendations four books on
the Spanish Civil War six books on deep
history of the American right
comprehensive biocracy disease of Adolf
Hitler of one of which I read I can
recommend uh six books in the Deep
history of the American left so American
right American left looking at the
history to give you the context
um biography of uh Vladimir Lenin two of
them on the French Revolution actually I
have never read a bag fan then maybe
that that would be useful everything's
been so Marx focused the Sebastian
biography of London is extraordinary uh
Victor Sebastian okay blow your mind
yeah so it's still useful incredible
yeah it's incredible I actually think
it's the single best book on the Soviet
Union so that the perspective of Lenin
it might be the best way to look at the
Soviet Union versus Stalin versus Marx
versus
very interesting so two books on Fascism
and anti-fascism uh by the same uh
author uh Paul Godfrey uh brilliant book
on the nature of mass movements and
Collective psychology the definitive
work on intellectual life under
totalitarianism the captive mind uh the
definitive worked on the Practical life
under total terrorism uh there's a bunch
there's a bunch and the single best book
first of all the list here is just
incredible but you say the single best
book I have found on who we are and how
we got here is the ancient city uh by
Numa Dennis festel di kulangus I like it
uh what's uh what did you learn about
who we are as a human civilization from
that book yeah so this is a fascinating
book this one's free but it's a free by
the way it's a it's a book in 1860s you
can download it or you can buy print out
prints of it but um it's uh it was this
guy who was a professor at the sorbond
in the 1860s and he was apparently a
savant on uh Antiquity on Greek and
Roman Antiquity um and the reason I say
that is because his sources are 100
original Greek and Roman sources so he
wrote a basically a history of Western
Civilization from on the order of four
thousand years ago to basically the
present times entirely working on Fresh
original Greek and Roman Roman sources
um and what he was specifically trying
to do was he was trying to reconstruct
from the stories of the grace of the
Romans he was trying to reconstruct what
life in the west was like before the
Greeks and the Romans which was in this
in this in the civilization known as the
the indo-europeans
um and the short answer is and this is
sort of Circa 4 000 you know 2000 BC to
you know sort of 500 BC kind of that
1500 year stretch where civilization
developed and his conclusion was
basically Cults
um they were basically Cults and the
civilization was organized into Cults
and the the intensity of the Cults was
like a million fold beyond anything that
we would recognize today like it was a
level of um all encompassing belief and
uh an action around religion
um that was at a level of extremeness
that we wouldn't even recognize it
um uh and and so specifically he tells
the story of basically there were three
levels of Cults there was the family
cult the tribal cult and then the city
cult as as Society scaled up and then
each call was a joint Cult of family
Gods which were ancestor gods and then
nature gods
and then you're bonding into a family A
Tribe or a city was based on your
adherence to that religion
um people uh who were not of your family
tribe City worshiped different gods
which gave you not just the right with
the responsibility to kill them on site
so they were serious about their Cults
hardcore by the way shocking development
I did not realize a zero concept of
individual rights like even even up
through the Greeks and even in the
Romans they didn't have the concept of
individual rights like the idea of it as
an individual you have like some right
it's just like nope right and you look
back and you're just like wow that's
just like crazily like fascist and a
degree that we wouldn't recognize today
but it's like well they were living
under extreme pressure for survival and
you and you know the theory goes you
could not have people running around
making claims to individual rights when
you're just trying to get like your
tribe through the winter right like you
need like hardcore command and control
and so and and actually what if through
Modern political lens those Cults were
basically both fascist and communist
um they were fascists in terms of social
control and then they were Communists in
terms of economics
but you think that's fundamentally that
like pull towards uh calls is within us
well so so my conclusion from this book
so so so so the way we naturally think
about the world we live in today is like
we basically have such an improved
version of everything that came before
us right like we we have basically we've
figured out all these things around
morality and ethics and democracy and
all these things and like they were
basically stupid and retrograde and were
like smart sophisticated and we've
improved all this um I I after reading
that book uh I I now believe in many
ways the opposite which is no actually
we are still running in that original
model we're just running in an
incredibly diluted version of it so
we're still running basically in Cults
it's just our Cults are at like a
thousandth or a millionth the level of
intensity right and so our so just to
take religions you know the modern
experience of a Christian in our time
even somebody who considers some a
devout Christian is just a shadow of the
level of intensity of somebody who
belong to a religion back in that period
and then by the way we have constr goes
back to our AI discussion we we we then
sort of endlessly create new calls like
we're trying to fill the void right and
the void is a void of bonding okay
living in their era like everybody
living today transporting that era would
view it as just like completely
intolerable in terms of like the loss of
freedom and the level basically fascist
a control however every single person in
that era and he really stresses this
they knew exactly where they stood they
knew exactly where they belonged they
knew exactly what their purpose was they
know exactly what they needed to do
every day they know exactly why they
were doing it they had total certainty
about their place in the universe so the
question of meaning the question of
purpose was very distinctly clearly
defined for them absolutely
overwhelmingly
undisputably undeniably so as we turn
the volume down on the cultism yes we
start to uh the search for meaning
starts getting harder and harder yes
because we don't have that we're we're
ungrounded we're we're uncentered and we
all feel it right and that's why we
reach for you know it's why we still
reach for religion it's why we reach for
you know these people start to take on
you know let's say you know a faith and
science maybe Beyond where they should
put it uh you know and by the way like
sports teams are like a you know they're
like a tiny little version of a cult and
you know the you know Apple Keynotes are
a tiny little version of a cult right
you know political you know yeah and
there's called you know there's full
blown calls on both sides of the
political Spectrum right now right um
you know operating in plain but still
not full-blown compared as to what it
was compared to what it used to I mean
we would today consider full-blown but
like yes they're they're at like I don't
know a hundred thousandth or something
of the intensity of what people had back
then so so we live in a world today that
in many ways is more advanced and moral
and so forth and it's certainly a lot
nicer much nicer world to live in but we
live in a world that's like a very
washed out it's like everything has
become very colorless and gray as
compared to how people used to
experience things which is I think why
we're so prone to reach for drama
because we there's something in US
deeply evolved where we want that back
and I wonder where it's all headed as we
turn the volume down more and more uh
what advice would you give to Young
Folks today
uh in high school and college how to be
successful in their career how to be
successful in their life yeah so the
tools that are available today I mean
are just like I sometimes you know I
sometimes bore uh you know kids by
describing like what it was like to go
look up a book you know to try to like
discover a fact and you know in in the
old days the 1970s 1980s go to the
library in the card catalog and the
whole thing you go through all that work
and then the book is checked out you
have to wait two weeks and like like
to be in a world not only where you can
get the answer to any question but also
the world now you know the AI world
where you've got like the assistant that
will help you do anything help you teach
learn anything like your ability both to
learn and also to produce is just like I
don't know a million fold beyond what it
used to be I have a I have a blog post
I've been wanting to write um I wish I
call uh where where are the hyper
productive people
um like the question right like with
these tools like there should be authors
that are writing like hundreds or
thousands of like outstanding books
well with the authors there's a
consumption question too but yeah well
maybe not maybe not you're right but so
the tools are much more powerful they're
getting much more musicians yeah right
why aren't musicians producing a
thousand times the number of songs right
um like what like the tools are
spectacular so what uh what's the
explanation and by way of advice like
what is motivation starting to be turned
down a little bit or what I think it
might be a distraction distraction it's
it's so easy to just sit and consume
um that I think people get distracted
from production but if you wanted to
um you know as a young person if you
wanted to really stand out you could get
on a like a a hyper productivity curve
very early on
there's a great uh you know the story
there's a great story in Roman history
of Pliny the Elder who was this
legendary Statesman
um died in the Vesuvius eruption trying
to rescue his friends but um he was
famous both for being a uh basically
being a polymath but also being an
author and he wrote apparently like
hundreds of books most of which have
been lost but he like wrote all these
encyclopedias and he literally like
would be reading and writing all day
long no matter what else was going on
and he so he would like travel with like
four slaves and two of them were
responsible for reading to him and two
of them are responsible for taking
dictation
and so like he'd be going cross-country
and like literally he would be writing
books like all the time and apparently
they were spectacular there's only a few
that have survived but apparently they
were amazing so there's a lot of value
to being somebody who finds focus in
this life yeah like one and there are
examples like there are uh you know
there's this guy uh judge uh what's his
name Posner postner um who wrote like 40
books and was also a great federal judge
um you know there's uh our friend
biology I think is like this he's one of
these you know where his his output is
just prodigious um and so it's like yeah
I mean with these tools why not and I
kind of think we're we're at this
interesting kind of freeze-free moment
where like this these tools are on
everybody's hands and everybody's just
kind of staring at them trying to figure
out what to do yeah but the new tools we
have discovered fire yeah and trying to
figure out how to use it to cook yeah
uh you told Tim Ferriss that the perfect
day is caffeine for 10 hours and alcohol
for four hours
you didn't think I'd be mentioning this
did you uh it balances everything out
perfectly as you said uh so let me ask
what's what's the secret to balance and
maybe to happiness in life
um I I don't believe in Balance so I
when I'm with the wrong person can you
elaborate why you don't believe in
Balance I mean I I maybe it's just and I
I look I think people I think people are
wired differently so I think it's hard
to generalize uh this kind of thing but
I'm I'm much happier and more satisfied
when I'm fully committed to something so
I'm very much in favor of it of
imbalance yeah
imbalance and that applies to work to
life to everything
yeah no no I happen to have whatever
Twist of personality traits lead that in
non-destructive Dimensions including the
fact that I've actually I now no longer
do the 10-4 plan I stopped drinking I do
the caffeine but not the alcohol so
there's something in my personality
where I I whatever maladaption I have is
inclining me towards productive things
not unproductive things so you're one of
the wealthiest people in the world
what's the relationship between wealth
and happiness oh uh money and happiness
so I think happiness
I don't think happiness is the thing to
strive for I think satisfaction is the
thing
that's that just sounds like happiness
but turned down a bit no deeper so
happiness is you know a walk in the
woods at Sunset an ice cream cone a kiss
um the first ice cream cone is great the
thousandth ice cream cone
not so much at some point the walks of
the woods get boring what's the
distinction between happiness and uh
satisfaction satisfaction is a deeper
thing which is like having found a
purpose and fulfilling it being useful
so just uh something that permeates all
your days just this General contentment
of
of being useful then I'm fully
satisfying my faculties that I'm fully
delivering right on the gifts that I've
been given that I'm you know not making
the world better that I'm contributing
to the people around me
right and that I can look back and say
wow that was hard but it was worth it
I think generally seems to lead people
in a better State than Pursuit pleasure
pursuit of quote unquote happiness does
money have anything to do with that I
think the founders of the founding
fathers in the US threw this off kilter
when they use the phrase Pursuit of
Happiness I think they should have said
they said pursuit of satisfaction we
might live in a better world today well
you know they could have elaborated in a
lot of things they could have tweaked
the Second Amendment I think they were
smarter than they realized they said you
know what we're going to make it
ambiguous and let these uh these humans
figure out the rest these tribal
cult-like humans figure out the rest
uh
but money empowers that so I I think and
I think there I mean look I think Elon
is I don't think I'm even a great
example but I think Elon would be the
great example of this which is like you
know look he's a guy who from every
every day of his life from the day he
started making money at all he just
plows into the into the next thing
um and so I think I think money is
definitely an enabler for satisfaction
it was supposed to say money applied to
happiness leads people down very dark
paths
very destructive Avenues uh money
applied to satisfaction I think could be
it is a real tool
um I always by the way I was like you
know Elon is the case study for Behavior
but the other thing that it's always
really made me think is Larry Larry Page
was asked one time what his approach to
philanthropy was and he said oh I'm just
my philanthropic plans just give all the
money to Elon
right uh well let me actually ask you
about Elon what what are your um you've
interacted with quite a lot of
successful engineers and business people
what do you think is special about Elon
we talked about Steve Jobs
what uh
what do you think is special about him
as a leader as an innovator yeah so the
the core of it is he's a he's he's back
to the future so he he is he is doing
the most Leading Edge things in the
world but with a with a really deeply
old school approach
um and so to find comparisons to Elon
you need to go to like Henry Ford and
Thomas Watson and Howard Hughes and
Andrew Carnegie right um Leila Stanford
um John D Rockefeller right you need to
go to the what we're called the
Bourgeois capitalist it's like the
hardcore business owner operators who
basically built you know basically built
industrialized Society
um Vanderbilt um and it's a level of
Hands-On commitments
um and uh depth um in the business
um coupled with an absolute priority uh
towards truth um and towards
um how to put Science and Technology uh
time to First principles that is just
like absolutely it was just like
unbelievably absolute he really is ideal
that he's only ever talking to Engineers
like he does not tolerate bullshit yes
let's bullshit anybody I've ever met
um he wants ground truth on every single
topic
um and he runs his businesses directly
day to day devoted to getting to ground
truth in every single topic so uh
you think it was a good decision for him
to buy Twitter I have developed a view
in life did not second guess Elon Musk
I know this is gonna suck Craig
crazy and unfounded but well I mean uh
he's got a quite a track record I mean
look the car was a crazy I mean the car
was I mean look she's done a lot of
things that seem crazy starting a new
car company in the United States of
America the last time somebody really
tried to do that was the 1950s and it
was called Tucker automotive and it was
such a disaster they made a movie about
what a disaster it was
um and then Rockets like who does that
like that's there's obviously no way to
start a rocket company like those days
are over and then to do those at the
same time
so after he pulled those two off like
okay fine like like this is one of my
areas of like whatever opinions I had
about that is just like okay clearly
they're not relevant like this is you
just you at some point you just like bet
on the person and in general I wish more
people would lean on celebrating and
supporting versus deriding and
destroying oh yeah I mean look he drives
resentment like it's like he is a magnet
for resentment
um like his critics are the most
miserable like resentful people in the
world like it's almost a perfect match
of like the most idealized you know
technologists you know of the century
coupled with like just his critics are
just bitter as can be I mean it's it's I
mean it's it's sort of very Darkly uh
comic to watch
well he uh he fuels the fire of that by
being an asshole on Twitter at times and
which is fascinating to watch the drama
of human civilization given our cult
roots
just fully on fire he's running a cult
say that very successfully so now now
there are Cults have gone and we search
for meaning what do you think is the
meaning of this whole thing what's the
meaning of life Mark kind reason I don't
know the answer to that um I think the
meaning of uh of uh the closest I get to
it is what I said about satisfaction so
it's basically like okay we were given
what we have like we should basically do
our best what's the role of love in that
mix I mean like what's the point of life
if you're yeah without love like yeah
so love is a big part of that
satisfaction but really they look like
they're taking care of people is like a
wonderful thing like you know a
mentality you know there are
pathological forms of taking care of
people but there's also a very
fundamental you know kind of aspect of
taking care of people like for example I
happen to be somebody who believes the
capitalism and taking care of people are
actually they're actually the same thing
um somebody once said capitalism is how
you take care of people you don't know
right
um right and so like yeah I think it's
like deeply woven into the whole thing
um you know there's a long conversation
we had about that but yeah
yeah creating products that are used by
millions of people and bring them joy in
smaller big ways and then capitalism
kind of enables that encourages that
David Friedman says there's only three
ways to get somebody to do something for
somebody else love money and force
love and money are better yeah that's a
good ordering I think we appreciate it
we should bet on those try love first if
that doesn't work the money yes and then
Force well don't even try that one uh
mark You're an incredible person I've
been a huge fan I'm glad to finally got
a chance to talk I'm a fan of everything
you do everything you do including on
Twitter it's a huge honor to meet you to
talk with you uh thanks again for doing
this awesome thank you Lex
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Mark Andreessen to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description and now
let me leave you with some words Mark
Andreessen himself
the world is a very malleable place
if you know what you want and you go for
it with maximum energy and drive and
passion
the world will often reconfigure itself
around you much more quickly and easily
than you would think
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time